I think this is the sixth hour and this
is my sixth costume change this is when
you can't decide between ugly plaid and
ugly camo get you a shirt that can do
both right hashtag waste of money we
done we done it we done it but you know
what account let's go this background
with these pillows so thank you all for
joining us if you're just joining us we
are playing our favorite games from the
Google Play Store until noon pacific
time tomorrow we need even half over
baby and i wore a watch or i can't even
see the hands why did i do that
for 24 hours i'm gonna stare at this
thing it's just a big black dumb dot but
so far we played a bunch of amazing
games let's talk about them shall we
Monument Valley to Lumino City Game of
Thrones conquest we played that game I
mean I was terrible at it but
technically we played it played some
animal crossing pocket camp with Sonam
obsession and David hopping Konitz to
assistance and while that was happening
pretty sure Conan was just wandering
around the lot drooling on himself
hidden folks which is an amazing kind of
word Where's Waldo adventure lineage to
revolution home escapes which is you
remember it's the sad Butler who goes
home to live with his parents and you
play a game where you're trying to just
make your parents house better by buying
carpets and stuff it's pretty fun you
guys should check it out it's actually
super addicting and then of course we
were joined by Todd Levin and Andre
Dupuis che 2 of our amazing hilarious
writers they played enigma spy adventure
game and oceanhorn
which I'm pretty sure was just walking
up and down a bunch of stairs fighting
beasts which isn't that life when we
think about it and then of course again
thank you to Chris Hayes Chris Brinson
and Jim Apollo for showing off their
amazing trivia skills there now they're
clapping let's see their name they clap
when I asked Lee clap they don't but as
soon as I give him a name check they
clap and a game called Sparkle I don't
know what that's about I mean I guess
it's a if a sport could tell the future
is an Oracle it's Sparkle I don't know
how they came up with that maybe it's
just all the letters in in not Yahtzee
in Scrabble that they couldn't get rid
of but we've got a long way to go and we
got a lot of great games to play and
right now we're
be cycling through because we have to
stop and continue do we cycle through
already oh I love it aren't I fantastic
so that's why I'm talking in wasting
time and if you have games you want us
to play please let us know in the chat
and we will try to get to them and we
have a lot of great costumes to get
through we have a lot more great games
to get through a lot more great great
guests to get through and I'm about to
introduce somebody in a second as soon
as they tell me it's okay and we have a
lot of great exclusive music
performances coming up later tonight to
keep you awake with some sweet
rock-and-roll and as well as some behind
the scenes goodies and of course you can
watch this I'm gonna try to get somebody
to to Conan's gum he left he left his
gum here in the very first hour and
we've got it here like a like a magical
nugget like one of the Infinity stones
you know I'm pretty sure I don't know
which one is this the soul gem or the
sad this is maybe the sad gem I think in
the Infinity stones this controls how
sad you can be
I don't know I'm keeping it and I keep
touching it and I don't know I kept
touching it and then touching other
people but I'm about to that right now
as we welcome please will help me
welcome I'm in Perugia yes thank you
you've now touched
Conan's gum by proxy I'm so sorry or
you're welcome
I don't know how ways are kind of cool
Conan's gum his gums not my favorite
part of them
thanks for coming I mean you're amazing
stand up you've been on our show yes and
you you're a big friend of the show how
did you first get into comedy and I'm
gonna as you answer this question I'm
gonna set up the game so it's kind of
we're gonna help each other
I always wanted to do comedy and when I
was in college I got a job at a comedy
club called stitches comedy cafe what do
they all have names like stitches and
yuckles and yeah it wasn't even spelled
if it was spelled with a k of course it
was it's a comedy club owners quick
poppy sa get better names man like the
yuk-yuk castle or something right yeah
what's that what's the dumbest club you
played the decides could the coalition
besides
stiches was not a great one it's up
there yeah it's up there so I was a
busboy there there but I oh really
you're a busboy yeah oh my god and then
you met at stage I didn't even know I
didn't know what comedy clubs were there
really I didn't know he didn't know
comedy clubs were I didn't know that
wasn't comically I guess I thought it
was like funny restaurant ha ha ha well
technically I guess if they serve food
there we go hear that
alright are you a gamer oh not copying
McCracken that's not a game yes this is
the better question especially beaver
you'd have this I'm not good but I well
look at me I'm Terra I can't even dress
myself look at this mess you know like
alright so here we go
also can I just give a shout out to
let's go back to the other shot give a
quick shout out to them I picked the
most obnoxious background in the history
of the world do not look directly the
screen because you will be blinded I
seriously can't even look at this yeah
it's crazy
oh my god let's never show that
background again I'm really sorry what a
mess I don't know it's like a punch it's
like a punch in the eyes basically what
an absolute mess I'm sorry we could get
off that shot now please Jesus let's
show the game oh my lord
all right so this is pixel gun 3d kind
of on the nose I mean it's a pixel a
it's a bunch of pixels and a gun it's
kind of like Minecraft meets Call of
Duty I guess those are pixels
yeah sorry peach one I know I think I
went a little too literal with the
background in terms of pixels it's a
zoomed-in pixel oh my god animus Prime
this background just messed up my LASIK
six hours ain't bad right lebarge that's
right
I love it are you gonna try to set the
old f.b.eye man alright so I'm not sure
shoot all enemies to finish training
what are our enemies yeah fear of
failure that's my enemy fear success is
my other one got a lot of fear exactly
you know it's like you know the old rule
of showbiz if you can make the band
laugh you know it's a good Jeff I say
when you're doing this tree if you can
make the crew laugh or the people
watching because everyone is so bored of
us right now so you can make them laugh
you know it's a great joke this is kind
of like minecraft guy caches are you out
of bullets no there you go you got him
sorry these are just I think these are
just dummies they're not real people see
I got the old crash-test dummy yeah
they're just cardboard boxes you're
super Saturn's here I gotta say like one
of the greatest things it's so hard when
you get older to get have to be happy
there's a kid like my parents would just
bring home a big box you know like oh
yeah when we bought a new refrigerator
it was like the greatest thing in the
world
yeah like oh my god yeah I'm a castle
ever rocket and now it's like I'm
unhappy with everything like a kid
walking just walking like he was like
yeah just a happy kid man we got to get
back to being happy about walking yeah
and I mean I'm happy about Christopher
Walken does that count watching the
Oscars that dude made me super happy
he's one of those guys who like the more
disheveled he looks the cooler he looks
you know his hair is all like looks like
he just woke up and like his belt was
kind of half like tied up and like but
he seems like cool I hope so because
that's a cool-looking dude man you look
like one of the extras from beating
Michael Jackson's beat oh don't stab
yourself though you're just I'm ending
it all I can't take it
what a mess
what did we do before pixel art you know
I think it's great that now you can get
like hyper realistic CG but we've gone
back to this you know just like oh here
we go upgrade yeah get that gun made out
of two pixels I wanted to get that Super
Soaker thing nothing like you do gonna
get it I don't think yeah we probably
have to do some good get going on some
missions or something oh my gosh
sound effects on point in pixel gun 3d
also I think you get like an octopus or
sometimes an employed gem he's going try
to get get out how do we get out of here
weapon primary maybe just go to Pitt
primary where's that and maybe if it's
it up here this thing Oh fry me okay a
tap out of the way tap on the where
category oh there's so many oh whoa I
see it wants us to get a thing all right
newbie armor we're noobs yeah definitely
it's pretty great this looks like
Wolfenstein gonna - you're right yo
Murphy moon Croft somebody's crisp
Christian Jill says moon Croft man we're
ready if anybody comes within two inches
of us we are ready to stab them that's
very exciting
oh here we go oh dude this music is the
tops or we play with other people
whoa this just got nuts oh my god
there's little butterflies I always get
really nervous playing with other people
because yeah people are real good yeah
don't shoot the dog though he's cool hit
from the left this just looks like a
nice park why can't we just like hang
out in the park no nor take a 79 goddess
like an Ortega does please try fate
Grand order okay how long we've been
streaming Maria asks this is our sixth
hour we started at noon I am just
realizing now we started at noon so when
I asked people how many hours there's
literally a clock that says the exact
hours and minutes that we've been
streaming and I'm dumb it's coming into
play again before the toy fires over yes
I am sure he will at some point Ortega
said yeah the guys probably 39 years old
cats sir again you are a Jesus I really
hate oh my look at this dude
I'm never gonna how do anyone there's
something like this God how do we get
cute husky situation I'm just gonna
watch him yeah well we can always if
this is too tough we can always switch
to another game we could give it a
couple more rounds then college
we're playing mobile games illegal
Eagles draf on City Christian Coleman Oh
dragon City there we go ha ha Jill says
graphics are almost as good as the moon
men from Aqua Teen Hunger version you're
speaking of the Adult Swim you're on a
show dreamcourt
first season available now second
seasons coming out this year what else
what is dream core not for people who
don't know what it is reading plays
place and first ones dream Corp or dream
Corps I never know what to sit or Cork
all right Gary McCrory should like a
corporation all right dream Court it
takes place in this dream in fact like a
therapy place where people come in to
get like you know their problems solved
and you go into their dream so you plug
them into this machine oh my god go in
it's kind of dangerous and the
equipment's old so they could die that
seems like a very unsafe then why would
I go in there I would seems very easy
usually people have been to their rope
Oh God I see the rector wins it that's
it you're just like so like let's say
okay so I have a problem I have a lot of
anxiety yeah so I come in there to
dreamcourt like all right let's see
we've been dreaming about yeah and
they'll kind of help you like face your
fears yeah okay you know they go deep
they dig deep to figure out I'm nervous
I don't want to face my fears they're
scary
well they disappeared well yeah I know
now once I know let's say so I've had my
I'm this reoccurring nightmare this is
actually not a joke this is totally true
yeah so help me can you help me solve my
problem all right it's basically not a
know where it comes from but it's
basically snakes all right with bat
wings for ears instead of eyes it's
antennas that come out they garner
reoccurring yeah it's reoccurring and
then also and this is also reoccurring
Keanu Reeves as John wick is there but I
know he's Keanu Reeves and he's not John
wick and then also and this is all
reoccurring by the way I'm not making
this up that's totally true then there's
also like so many's apartments and
there's like people playing acoustic
guitar and it's kind of like a dorm but
you know in a dream it's not
all that's happening the snakes they're
just around there like trying to bite
you they're just sitting there not and
they're blind and so they're kind of
like any of like weird bat wings that's
a real thing guys somebody diagnosed me
so I know there's a doctor in the chat
because you know a very messy oh my god
I'm basically like a hoarder I mean look
at this yeah oh my god it's that I have
too much stuff
whoa now I was talking earlier I'm a
harpoon in my bathroom that Chris makes
for the set yeah I mean maybe that's
part of it maybe it's like I'm
attracting these bad vibes yeah right
what a decoration if you sit there yes I
want to go like car whaling or something
you know like hey you drink too much or
something and then ya whip up our food
you know typical East Hollywood stuff
you know it's ridiculous
you're a doctor without a diploma Meisel
usual of Zeena's so what's up so tell me
what's uh what's going on
they represent Kona coming together
scooby-doo you're right you had a
nightmare about Darth Vader eating you
he doesn't even have a mouth how does
that even happen
you know what the notes show in Star
Wars Darth Vader eating well drinking
through straws I mean he's not gonna
take it to think I've every time he has
to drink you know but I've just got a
little just a little tiny drink straw
and not like a real one - like one of
the ones they give you at a bar can't
even really drink zombies get stuck in
an ice cube going it's just like veins
popping out of your head his stuff yeah
yeah you know that's a really good
question guys question for the chat kid
Darth Vader get his stuff the monster
sounds like dratini - the eyes real
Wellman says what's dratini is that like
a martini but with like it's like would
rate would Drake drink some martini it's
a dratini
it's special here it goes zero to 100
real quick thank you thank you I hate
myself all right
how reoccurring can it be well Jared
John wick came out I mean at least three
or four years ago right Beth what did
John wick come out forever I thought
what 2014 so it's been recurring sits
around 2014 I thought honestly I just
asked Beth because she's a huge a
hardcore John wick fan aren't you yeah
she's you know she's not a camera so she
can't say no so it's funny to see
comedians integrate their app into a
conversation it's not a bit man that's
one you want me to take over in Utah you
can't be worse than me why did I see
somebody get killed quick all right here
we go one thing is hard is that the move
button is also the shoot book oh yeah
this is - can't move and shoot yeah
that's why they you know what that's why
they created a controller although you
know what I think there's a there are
other people in this game playing with a
controller I just shoot people makers
its main it's maniac I got shot by all
right let me have one more chiming in
your we're gonna switch to a different
game this game is giving me anxiety yeah
this game is like snakes this is my
snakes coming out of is somebody the dog
the dog why is that guy shooting me
we're on a team here man
ah alright I've dealt with it let's go
fullscreen we can't I can't play pixel
gun 3d anymore it's driving me insane I
need I need like a nap after this this
is not the game to play oh you know what
now I can't see because so now we're
gonna play a little game I like to call
bad land because that's the name of it
so that's why we should call it yeah
exactly
I have a new comedy album out oh yeah
now what's the name of it tell people
about it
almond but do t know is that duty like
duty or duty like it's your duty it's a
duty like duty Oh Doody where does I
miss pronunciation of my name cuz ah
comedian you just got have gotten
everything so that's that's one of the
names I've gotten meaning the name I say
how did almond Duty how long did it take
you to come up with that material
what's your first Oh congratulations man
thank my god this is huge
wow so it was yes 10 years when I
recorded it
Wow all the material it took 10 years
wow that's amazing and then how did you
decide how did you decide what makes it
on the album what doesn't um yeah I
guess you know I wanted to be about an
hour so so it kind of just started
picking my favorite like the jokes I
like them you know the ones that are
past that I cut them away right so once
I got to an hour this is about feels
good yeah it feels pretty good yeah
pretty much as all of the jokes I like
because I think is like why not now not
to make you nervous when you cut now
buts there forever those are the jokes
yeah it was the ones up top
you know nobody took me a lot of record
one you know all right I'm gonna do one
five years in and then like regret it of
course yes uh that's great all right
we're gonna play the other tablet now
guys just so you know no not not that
one just this one here
yeah so bad land is a game we don't need
to play bad land to quite yet bad land
is a game where you're a little thing
now I know I just said what I was scared
of which was snakes with bat wings for
years and a test and this is kind of
you're playing kind of a creature like
right maybe I need to stop playing very
mobile games this one looks more mice if
anyone has any paper towel over there
that'd be great I missed someone's
comment just said if you take a look at
the stream at five hours something about
me and then it said that we're dying and
that's probably correct that's probably
correct thank you so much almond Duty
every governor you got it you got it
Rene you got it okay cool you know I
guess we're gonna have to have to switch
this thing over because I'm done so I
think you're a little like tiny little
bat guy okay
I think we're gonna turn this valley up
so we can hear it so that's cool and got
to get the right input always the right
input that's you there you are see more
cute really than scary no yeah yeah I
think you just got I guess just life man
I can do this yeah there we go
I mean you're a natural at this yeah now
I don't want to get gross yeah this is
kind of a bit of an almond Duty yeah you
know I thought it's kind of like if your
almond Edie we're definitely uh Sandra
the paper towel is for this water which
I just knocked over with my flailing
limbs by giant flailing I don't know if
you've ever as a child made like a
cartoon paper mache puppet but that's
basically me in real life it's a mess
did it Oh next level dude way if it hit
that next level boom way better
do you are a natural it badly so you
just gotta fit the game that's all it is
that's all it is
where's your dad says Edwin Arroyo well
I don't know I don't I mean I'm not sure
we should get into it on a public chat
but let's just say he made some bad
decisions and he's being punished for
them hey bees music what's up
huge alley lucky la alley lucky luck I
don't speak French unfortunately
although you know I took five years of
it how are you with other languages do
you speak other languages barely
basically forever of Spanish can't
figure it out I think you got a I think
you gotta suck up those little glowing
things I'm not ignoring you Sandra Ford
Walter's English in America doesn't it
to ice me get nice look at a tiny you
are wait you said you don't speak of it
like you tried Spanish but you couldn't
figure it out yeah I love you know I
took at least five years of Spanish and
I can you know speak very very like to
my neighbor I can say like okay oh no
it's your neighbor have a lot of
problems what's a good thing you know
those words if you are huge right now
bye guys bloated this is like me after
nutty drinking just trying to get to off
the couch oh yes good job Bobby
killing it uh Kevin Hawk this game is
called bad land it's available on Google
Play a lot of nights now it's pretty fun
although it does remind me of my
nightmares but you know what I think
we're working through this because he's
pretty cute and we're having a good time
yeah yeah next time you're in the dream
just to invite the snakes up invited by
you know a real bitey they're real like
I'm not like those antenna things too
it's really scary they're real quick I
don't know they're from Mexico
Eduardo wants to hear your Spanish wait
can you say are you okay in Spanish do
you member I said two guys I oughta say
it that's too bad right that's a billion
yeah
there we go we did is that right and a
Philips what's up and if Philip says I
have lovely nightmares I think you're
mocking if you like snakes this is girl
the snakes I could speak to alien can I
do you remember yes chill weekend
DJ mom jeans in the house oh yeah this
is kind of like flappy bird but wait oh
my god you got like multi-ball thank god
this reminds you've been if you ever
play limbo no it's a cool game called
limbo it's actually also a google play
oh no oh yes yes DLNA get the snakes
drunk Rene I've tried trust me does the
dream wake me up says Madeleine Sims
sometimes it wakes me out
sometimes it does it and those are the
bad ones you ever in the dream realizes
the dream I have only one time I a lucid
dream they call it yeah only one time
I've had a lucid dream
really and that yeah have you read lucid
dream I think so yeah I'm usually it's
when I have a reoccurring dream because
I'm like I know this oh man oh that's
awesome
so maybe you're snakes you can I don't
know [ __ ] well I guess you're right and
then I kept like like to hold my snakes
[Music]
snakes good this is what I do there's
nothing getting rid of snakes which is
probably why they keep attacking me cuz
I go
I'm very Norm Macdonald but it's like
hey hey you snakes
I know I know lucid dream once where I
was in the kitchen in my parents house
and this is so boring are you ready for
the most boring dream you could possibly
have yes that's what happened I was in
my parents house and I was like opening
a cabinet door and the handle this is
totally true the handle in the cabinet
door was the handle of the door in the
house I grew up in of the cabinet I was
like wait a second
door handle but I swear to god I'm the
most boring dreamer snakes in John wick
aside and I was like there's a different
handle of a thing and then I was like oh
my god I'm dreaming that and then I
looked outside and it was like a
different backyard that way I was like
oh my god this is and all of a sudden
was like I was being pulled up like from
deep water kind
no no I don't wanna wake up I woke up
was that crazy yeah it was about so
basically in a dream where you could do
any yeah you just realize there's a yeah
all I did was like recognize a different
cabinet handle I'm flooring is that I
could have gone to the Playboy Mansion I
could have gone skydiving I could have
been like a superhero
instead I was like look at this cabinet
door it's different look at the backyard
that I woke up I mean idiots wait do you
remember your lucid dream yeah usually
whenever I realize I'm dreaming I
usually flying oh yeah of course you
just want to mostly because it's usually
a bad dream that I'm you know as I said
like a reoccurring one sure I've been
here before and then I'm like I can fly
away I know what happens do you like
this guy
yeah this is you this is why I like this
game so much this reminds me of snippy
Lopez says this runs you a classic PSP
game called loco loco there we go
everything is real and also unreal when
Wayne law to with some deep knowledge in
the chest mind you can only dream about
things you've experienced before that's
not true what about the snakes with the
Buccaneers in the eyes you must have
seen it that's right
survivor your depressingly obsessed with
what rod or note Hey hello Greece hello
Greece Prozac inside is one my favorite
games there's a great game called inside
where you're a kid you got a pair of
these puzzles and it's really creepy
great oh my god there's so many of us
dude you about to hit the club yo oh my
god you are greatest Oh Julie Lyons is
bored by this game Julie what do you
want from a game well what more can you
ask then little tiny almond duties with
wings flying around what do you want
from us
Brad s decided lucid Rubik ona making
fun of George Clancy
maybe you just left it you might have
just left the left the show on while
you're sleeping
what's dreamed I was at work and then
woke up at home Oh reckless Raven Hubble
star I go back to a dreamland during my
nightmares there's always a bridge and
Road that wraps around water every
nightmares the same settings dreams are
weird
yeah I need them I need a better
dreaming situation yeah maybe I need to
look at like some weird stuff before I
go to bed a lot of candy oh yeah well
then yeah I just drink maybe I should
drink like a whole bottle of maple syrup
you know there's that great have you
seen super troopers yes so there's that
famous scene it's so if you guys haven't
seen super troopers is about this this
guy this this bunch of Highway Patrol
guys who are a bunch of idiots and their
play pranks each other
there's a scene a famous scene there
where they have a contest or they're
chugging maple syrup and in the
directors commentary they say that they
all had day jobs during this and so they
went and shot that scene like they like
on a break from work yeah and they each
drank like three bottles of syrup and
then they had to go back to of her do
they drink real serious yeah there's
like good cuz I mean it's kind of hard
to fake me out sir because it's like
viscous Gingrich says you could train
yourself to lucid dream I use do it how
do you train yourself I would love to
learn how to do
like way to do that I've heard like
something by your bed or maybe yeah you
like always like you punch yourself in
the face really yeah let's see what's
the training system sauce berries taste
like snozberries hey Kevin did you know
the snozberries guy is married to
Christina Hendricks who was
what's-her-face and he's even and he
said yes yeah what's his name
snozberries guy he's also a five hundred
a lemur oh my god that's awesome
a drink court Hamid show is available
the first season on Adult Swim tonight
now season two coming this year that's
fun how did you get involved with Tree
Park you have to audition how did it
work
I did yeah creator Daniel Stetson he he
worked on a commercial that I worked in
remember me from that and let me
audition and then whoa that's great he's
super super awesome and creative the
show's just like super psychedelic and
trippy that's fun that's got to be fun
to work on Mike yeah the second season
two just got even crazier he's kind of
an episode where I turn into an oh my
god what happened like did you have like
makeup and prosthetics or yeah oh my god
really how did you how many days did you
have to shoot in that stuff I think
mostly one that it was an 18-hour days
holy Moses although I'm probably better
to shoot for 18 hours I have to keep
coming in and get yeah four hours of
makeup like let's just get this done the
same phibian means business what how
intense was the makeup in the
prosthetics that's pretty intense like
you couldn't even see like my whole face
I do you know
headpiece and then skin was covered hey
porky what's going on hey thanks to you
appreciate the love
we're here with Ahmed brooch if you
could see it show a dream Corp on Adult
Swim currently season one and they're
doing some season two action see if
they've been in season one or season -
oh it's so it's coming up no that's
great
our playing the game bad land which is
great and kind of reminds us both about
our night no reminds me about my
nightmares you like this he likes it
this is a dream for him for me it's a
nightmare and we are playing 24 hours of
mobile games in the Google Play Store
I'm playing until noon tomorrow we play
games like vitamin Valley - we've played
games like Sparkle we've played games
like home escapes and we are taking your
suggestions for games to play because we
got a lot of hours to play these games
hey pink combo it's why it's his day
bears that's true not nightmares
teammates
Daniel Karras I thought there's a
smartphone game only a lot of these
games are for tablets and phones we're
playing on these shield tablets which
were super fun and the perfect size to
hold I think is available to for phones
Gollum makeup gala mica well God
actually wasn't Renee Gollum wasn't
makeup that was like a motion mocap I
think yeah especially as doink doink
doink doink doink I chaired the guy from
guardians of the galaxy his was like
you stand like this oh my god really
six or eight hours the group guy yeah no
uh the guy with all the tattoos Oh
Batista yeah Wow
that's nuts and you had to be a little
bit there maybe he slept too babyish
ever like holy Moses that's crazy yeah I
thought that was great guards yeah it
was super those are super Lords are you
accomplish man you looking forward to
infinity war uh yeah I mean I'm not like
a big you don't need to almost better I
think yeah this is my my best friend's a
huge conical person and I think it's
like harder to enjoy one you know yeah
they're tortured that's to have you seen
Black Panther yet did you
now did you steal the baby or did ya
just bang the baby will be fine yeah
what's the I think yeah get a free baby
yeah yeah that's kind of fun if you just
see you see a baby liner I just take it
take a big congratulations how old your
baby wow my god are you still in the
zone of no sleep yeah Oh got it
that's why you kids if you're not asleep
that's awesome first baby first pain oh
my god what's one thing that surprised
you the most about having fake makers
keepers exactly
by the way it's real - yeah it's real
I'm usually pretty good sleep
different would like someone else
stopping you when it's not your choice
yeah I love it I know I like I'm
normally just like I'm read it like all
night yeah then if it's my baby I'd be
like God I get why there's so many why
do they become so many of you it seems
like it's kind of helped like so I it's
kind of like alive oh I see
oh I see it's it kind of like gives you
better change yeah
David LaBrie playing minesweeper you
don't want us to play minesweeper
probably Andy Richter I've just returned
the baby
[Music]
you're right pin combo Freddy Krueger
can't stop you cuz you're not sleeping
you're you can defeat Freddy Krueger
you'd be one of the drink because you
know you're never sleeping that's you
know I think that you can meet him but
yeah that's true that's a great piece of
advice out there if you're being stalked
by Freddy Krueger we have a baby yeah
meet meet a partner that you want to
have a baby with have a baby and the
Freddy Krueger can't get you yeah it
took for at least a couple you're the
best reason a baby that's right aye sir
milk we are playing a game called bad
land which is super fun the Krampus eats
babies
Krampus the Jason moves in next door I
don't know I think we're creating a
crazy who wanted a Freddy vs. Jason I
don't remember
escape game yes Chris you called me this
is kind of like an escape game it's kind
of like limbo it's kind of like it's
like limbo meets flappy bird I think it
was great limbo meets flappy bird
there's not really a story but I think
if we had to make a story up those dad
yes look for it like Edwin in the chat
yeah I didn't wonder why there's all
these gears what are all these gears
running yeah it's rats padlet
the land is bad yeah isn't this is based
on the Bruce Springsteen song almost
exactly this is dope yeah thanks Natan
adventure thanks for watching it's
babbling yeah
play add you what do you mean how'd you
do oh we've got some dots were lighting
up I like that micro naps that's what
people are saying to you yeah yeah can
you just fall asleep immediately no like
I'm insomniac so it's a lot of falsely
no no that's not good wait now are we
talking like to block out the light for
the puffiness around the eyes cuz you
have great skin you're lookin good
yeah I mean I'm getting some
moisturizers I'm guessing no really Oh
natural you must drink a lot of water
greasy a lot of greasy food that's what
it is there we go light yeah oh yeah
right it's all about head towards them
oh my god oh god
oh boy it's some point you should just
be able to I think Ron got flapping I
mean when you're huge what's the problem
direct breaks a lot of water and coffee
and wine as we learned in Italy Johanna
new boss says please play neko atsume
kitty collector I think we have that one
downloaded thank you Anna
just sleep in your overs okay I'm not
taking a lot of ER so I'm really worried
about my sleep yeah people are nervous
right now
people do get crazy about it's hard to
sleep in an uber to talk to you yeah I
know I hate that somebody please tell
all the lyft and uber drivers out there
you get more stars the less you say yeah
does anybody what like you're like I
wish my uber would talk to me oh darn it
yeah and maybe every once in a while you
wanna know never here's what I hate I
the thing I hate the most is when you go
to get a haircut yeah all right and the
person talks to you a lot all right and
then the next time you go back though
yeah welcome back and then they just and
it just grows from there now I know what
I'm describing is a personal connection
with another but I have to say man like
I have like no stopped going to hair
people because it's like I don't I can't
listen your life for 40 minutes I just
want a quick in-and-out of haircut
zum-zum get me over there I think I
can't deal with this it's doing yeah
what were you going you know this is
your own work well done man let's see
the back oh that's great
oh it looks great this is a mess this is
a half wig this parts of the plastic
piece that fits on there staples it's a
mess it's a whole nother if you get a
massage that's a person you don't
realize oh I hate massages - I don't
like people touching me yeah you
definitely need that yeah I got a
massage once and I you know what I bet I
could even find the photo I'm gonna find
it
here we go foe sex says I want Strome to
the next town over for a haircut you're
feeling me on this yes me too
I mean I never have but I will I would
have it that's right
not for barbers we have no soul okay
fair enough Alex what also just a humble
star hates that too almost are hates
people - guys let's band together and
talk to our masseuses and our our hair
dressers about not talking to us or
touching us you know we do water
masseuses - touches yeah your hair
saying we had our time exactly sleep
during my hair cuts Christina I can't
look what if like I have a weird you
ever like a trip in your dream yes and
then you go like boom like yeah what if
I do that one sleep and I get a scissor
right in the eye
you know rs scissors would be what I get
a scissor and the iris scissors in the
only both like a scissor one pair of
pants is just called a pain right yeah
is it called a pant I don't know I don't
know the plural I don't know how to
speak things I barely speak English but
I did get a massage one time and I'm
gonna show you guys a picture cuz this
is more of a PSA than anything else
let's see if I can find it here cuz you
know I was my back hurt so I went to
decides to get it all worked out and I
said when I went in there like what kind
of massage do you want do you want like
a soft massage do you want like
something a little guy go like athletic
and I was like yeah they're like well
harder stuff I was like do your worst is
what I said now let me just explain
something that I learned that day the
hard way yeah don't ever say that to
somebody whose job it is to squeeze and
punch things because this is what
happens look at this that's what
happened right there guys do your worst
lay that look at that neck oh my god
yeah
it destroyed I don't you can't anyway it
was a it's a mess yeah dude it's like
somebody took like a baseball bat just
it's like somebody went like I was like
house like okay do your worse or like
coming right up
they just did this like 20 minutes
they're like okay that'll be $900 you
know what they did and they had some
great music on too and I was just kind
of trying to get to the vibe and they're
like so I've been in LA long and I was
like like also like what's keeping like
one-word answers exactly you know anyway
your ex-girlfriend was a massage
therapist
well hope you didn't get a massage after
white because that would be horrifying
investors of good ear buds cuz you'll
need a break from the kitty noise ooh
that's a thing for you thank you cry for
help
yeah yeah he doesn't cry too much yeah
yeah exactly
cue em Heisenberg good lord well and my
son's name is Walter whoa awesome what
was a great name yeah
Walt's Walter Aaron is not a good name
you know why because it's a a so I'm the
first in everyone's phone so I get
butt-dialed like three times a week on
it right well you got a aah is that a
man that's right up top - it's right up
top it's it's the worst
[Music]
the pad is out there will be blood
that's right it's 6:45 guys the Sun is
down and the bat is out and I'm waving
it around looking crazy nice it's not a
good list yeah we got I really got 50
more minutes I bet you can beat this
game infinity that's right hey yeah hey
Ron exactly hey hey by the way how great
is it the Jordan Peele won an Oscar oh
my god so great you see the photo of
keegan-michael key yeah that's so funny
it's great weirdly keegan-michael Keys
dad and my mom used to work next to each
other their offices were next to each
other what uh Sarah pused uh and so I
have a plant that he gave my mom in her
kitchen that's super weird so like and I
never met Keegan but I think that would
be something I'm probably not gonna tell
them that all right so your dad yeah dad
gave my mama plants it's a bit weird
stay with me what were you going
Keegan where you going that's true that
small world small world Aaron Wallis
that's right your name and my name are
the same hey Ron that's right everyone's
calling me negan I'm kind of like a
negan like a hipster
I don't think meeting where this he's
more of like a leather jacket yeah and
also he's got a barbed wire on his back
which is just very unsafe yeah it's
really hard to play baseball at the bar
boy no just the ball kind of sticks to
it uh Scott emblems this is called bad
land its enemy oh my god what's
happening here let's switch the game Oh
mouse can you put the game on thanks pal
oh my god Wow
good lord this game's called bad land
it's available on Google Play like all
the games are playing for the next
however many hours and terrible at math
Badlands Thank You Johnny Lee orange of
blue camo so la is this I guess it is
the big SiC was great - yeah big sick
yeah and Kumail and Emily you know them
you must know them yeah they're great
people great folks during the comedy
scene around here good peeps I was
really bummed they lost but again they
got nominated yeah I mean yeah it was
cool see Camille there yeah absolutely
that was great yeah he did teach it some
presenting which I thought was awesome
love y'all love you too Danielle thank
you Daniel Strasburg Dylan sharp you can
win an Oscar I guess we couldn't win
Oscars what would you win an Oscar for
and what what would you wanna win our
acting yeah be fun right yeah Jordan won
for Best Original Screenplay but he was
nominated for directing also three
differently three other people ever have
been nominated for those yeah I think so
[Music]
cool this dude yeah yeah orange and blue
camo it's actually guys to be fair let's
go fullscreen on this one I think this
is important I just want to point out
this is blue camo and then it's orange
plaid so get it one it's an orange of
blue camo it's borns plaid and blue camo
that's a camo so good you can't even
tell exactly right exactly camouflage is
the plan all right so you can go back I
wanted to make a point about like
disgusting shirt it is it is an honor to
be nominated Jarrod I would say yeah
because I think like here's what I think
the nominations are kind of done by your
peers right and kind of the winning not
to take anything away from winners
because winning is amazing but it's also
kind of like the heat who's got the heat
that year and that's kind of a hard
thing to you know a lot of times yeah
like it's kind of you getting a scrum
and it's kind of you know whatever the
public thinks but I think it truly is an
honor because the nomination how many
people looking up
yeah Thank You Ana it is a fabulously
horrible shirt Ninth Circuit overlearn
ah so it fits into a norm corp hipster
bar under water I don't know what that
means
who knows trend starter urban survival
shirt that's right oh thanks live boys
six four that's nice to say ladybird had
a lot of heat lady I haven't seen
ladybird yet but credit girl wait man
that's just like unreal at 26 like like
amazing director so good yeah I didn't
get to see a lot of babysitting yeah
that's true I did see get out oh there
we go yeah
yeah yeah Kim oh this is a useless camo
but I guess a fad this fashion statement
says I don't know you were killing it
right now this is also a game your baby
can play you just have to be a hit one
thing which is fantastic hello Gabriel
Oberto who on the Razzie clique Adelphia
asks the emoji movie didn't won the
Razzie this year yeah by the way props I
think Halle Berry
she went for Catwoman actually showed up
to accept her Rousey really I love rice
you'd be great I would like anymore I'll
take it I'll take whoa this is awesome
holy crap yes oh my god this is amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
this is awesome
yes that was incredible
wow that was amazing this is an amazing
game it's super exciting it's also
beautiful yeah and it gets like more
complexes you guys feel like kind of
first in like I just tap in button oh I
think we got infected by something as
soon as we said beloved in it it hurt us
there's a there's some kind of lesson in
there so work
oh thanks kiddo I can't play
I know Lumiere says I can't believe
submitted the idea to make the emoji
maybe listen people will make movies out
about anything there's gonna be sequel
three people refused their Oscars who
were they so I think well famously like
Marlon Brando did right he wouldn't show
up I think it was protests like for
something about the environment or
Native Americans then I don't know I
know that that's a famous one but I love
that Roger Deakins one because I'm a
huge nerd he's a cinematographer who's
done a ton of the Coen Brothers movies
he did Blade Runner he did Sicario he's
been nominated 14 times he's like the
Meryl Streep yeah cinematography and
he's so chill he's like the coolest
chillest guy and he finally won aa Blade
Runner which is great very cool-looking
movie that's not a great movie
I have adorable thank you weird you're
just joining us mirror with Hamid
Bharucha you can see his show dream Corp
the first seasons available on Adult
Swim second season is coming out this
year and his very first comedy album is
out now so go buy it it's awesome it's
called almond Duty not based on this
game coincidence
what's not wait what if a little green
oh good gravy
lady Space Marine what are your what are
your thoughts on Blade Runner 2049 did
you see it I didn't see it yet I'm
behind on all the movies because of the
baby he's got a child he's raising a
child get off this back about it ah I
thought the new was awesome I really
liked it yeah
Jared Leto or Leto wasn't too annoying I
love me a good Gosling Yeah right
everybody was great Harrison Ford was
great everybody was great it was
beautiful weird very slow which I liked
oh so many he's like being the king of
oh king of remakes yeah for sure and
then he's also then cuz I think he plays
Jack Ryan right so he's played like cuz
Alec Baldwin first played Jack Ryan okay
then he played Jack Ryan so he's played
how many characters has you played we're
trying to think of like how many
different franchises he's been yeah so
like the Tom Clancy stuff yeah obviously
Star Wars Indiana Jones a Blade Runner
that's four I think we can do better
yeah what else has he been guys help us
out bus denis villeneuve is the best
director working today
did he is incredible so good you wish
you could sleep crush crazy I'm gonna
wish that to Paris fortnight to great
games
what books am i reading now are you up
are you a reader big reader I wish I was
no I wish I could read a sleep training
book there we go no wait a second what's
the what's the single most important
thing for sleep training little quiz I'm
pretty whiskey would be the solution I
would say you kind of get it basically
the baby just has to learn how to put
themselves to sleep come house can you
show the game so I'd say like stepping
back stepping away because I think a lot
of times just you think baby needs self
shoes self is I wish I could do that
[Music]
favorite movie of all time
come on lit boy I can't pick a favorite
movie yeah that's a good one I need some
I think it changes it's always changing
there are movies for sure that when they
come on I can't turn them off weirdly
Gattaca ago I don't know why there's a
lot of dumb and dumber I could watch
that with Dumb and Dumber repeat that's
right
Zemo is the best rhythm game ever all
right we'll have to play it what I think
of the Oscars I thought they were great
you know I'm not a huge Awards Show guy
I think I thought you know I'm all for
like message of inclusion was great all
that stuff was awesome but generally I
don't really like award shows and also
like when you live in LA the Oscar is
like shuts down Holly I mean obviously
like it's going to but it's like the day
before you can't park anywhere it's all
it's a real that's how big of a first
world complaint didn't shut up I need to
shut my mouth
oh I'm sad because the Oscars are near
us it's great the Oscars are do least
favorite movie of all time I think I've
only walked out of one movie I think it
was like blue heat or key why don't we
put ahead of Alec Baldwin the 90s it was
the terrible oh yeah you know what wait
a second maybe that's why I have the
weird snake yeah isn't that kind of an
Alien Resurrection no damn the things in
the tubes there yeah oh my god wait I
think we just had a major breakthrough
god yeah oh I don't know well especially
if it's a terrible movie
Kenneth says your baby is probably 200
times cooler than both of us squared I
hope so I'm sure yes I'm sure you want
your baby to be cooler than you and
everyone's cooler than me I mean look at
this shirt this is ridiculous
so yes how do I feel about the new Elder
Scrolls yeah yeah today it's all my baby
cool yeah every exactly your baby's
pretty cool you got a good new baby on
it take it back yeah meet the Spartans
walked out of that in the first 10
minutes very sharknado
you know what there are movies that are
so terrible it's hard to uh yeah exactly
lunar on yeah there you go you got a
shout out congratulations you got all
day yeah this is great
you know what when you can't sleep this
is the game to play uh Oh favorite
horror film John Carpenter's a thing for
me easy there was a point at which I saw
every horror movie a blockbuster
perfect alright I think we're gonna end
there we're out of time everybody
thank you I'm in brucha great again
check out this brand-new and first
comedy album almond Duty out now make
sure you check out dream Corp and the
first students available on Adult Swim's
second season coming out this year and
he plays an afib Ian man this man was in
for hours and make up for you kills
right you had guilt yeah it was crazy
was in a harness so check it out don't
let that work go wasted of course you
can follow my Twitter at I'm at brucha
and I'm in Sergei Mohammed burrito and
that's I'm gonna spell it for people so
they can think is that Alright let me
know if I get this right let's hear it
we're gonna see if our producer wrote
this correctly at @h m e d b har OCH a
yes really killed it well done right
also I'm at brutal calm thank you so
much I'm it and now it is the top of the
hour so I think it's time to check in
with mr. Conan O'Brien let's see what
he's got to say guys alright it is 7
o'clock it is 7 o'clock if you didn't
have a drink at 5:00 you can definitely
have a drink now I know I'm a little
obsessed with when you can have a drink
and I'm not suggesting you drink cuz I
don't think you should I'm just saying
if you're old enough you want to have a
little something that's your business
but 7 o'clock is a fairly decent time
and I'll be honest with you if you drink
late sugar is gonna be in your brain
you're not gonna sleep well 7 o'clock
make sure you have food with the drink
uh I should stop talking about drinking
my hand shaking I need a little
something
but I should probably talk about this on
camera anyway I hope you're enjoying
this 24 hour sizzle for everybody
welcome back and now we keep up with a
crazier background to match my crazy
shirt I love it is 7 o'clock we are 7
hours into our 24-hour mobile marathon
sponsored by Google Play and again we're
not even halfway through baby we're only
we're only point word point
40 puts out a word not even halfway
through so don't worry about it somebody
do the math on that um look again we
have a bunch of special guests coming up
we'd have a bunch more great games to
play
I'm chewing on some candy that's where
we're at because you know what now we're
gonna start to fight the fatigue I love
it let's get into it
our next guest is one of my favorite
people on the show and not just because
he's got the same color hair as me
please welcome Levon Dougal everybody
[Applause]
Hey look at this guy couple of silver
foxes I love it Oh Levi say hi to twitch
YouTube and Facebook and tell them what
you get hey guys just lays right here
left yes play game I love it did some
bits to it just as a judge earlier oh
really yeah what was the bit cuz people
haven't seen the show yet so give them a
little sneak peek oh yeah I just playin
judge granting citizenship to ask
someone on the show
alright fantastic and you'll have to
watch the show tonight to see who that
person is that's right I love it
alright we're gonna play a game called
Republic where is it Republic I don't
know public I guess it's republic yeah
maybe you will say the name in the game
you know like if you ever you ever
watched like Suicide Squad but they're
like what are we just some kind of
Suicide Squad you say what is this some
kind of Republic or Republic right
that's what you know for hopefully in
the game they'll say what is it some
kind of suicide that would be truly
amazing you want to play sure all right
gang here hit the old play button there
okay now don't let this alarm you this
is a green screen we are not gonna be
in the game we're not here we're just
overlaid here it's dude they can't hurt
us I don't have to watch this know what
we're playing no I mean you probably
could have you oh cool this is gonna go
on I love that things happen like here
save new game well let's go now wait do
we want the store I think we want the
easier experience because nobody likes
it when they watch me struggle playing
yeah we don't need to oh no that's
I love it all right here we go episode 1
I'm really hoping like in the first two
minutes they say Republic or Republic oh
we got a call now oh no nope never never
open alright let's answer the call man
you name this is just literally we're
just talking on the phone I heard this
game it's all phone call yeah we're just
a call center catch up on your bed oh
they are that's a really good looks like
maybe that's a is that a baby monitor
and back there maybe she has a baby it
could I think just a camera
boy so I hit the eye and heard of this
okay
killed her just like an ashen shadow
it's the game Oh
so remember dad that wasn't easy yeah
real quick loved it oh and I don't know
baby buggies to look around or pull yeah
okay okay so I just hit the eye again
she's not you know I don't like it when
people on skype make phone calls and
then just are all jittery you know I
appreciate that you know hold it hold
this day oh so we can
[Music]
yes oh my god Sunni some people watching
sense knew and they went to the store
walk there knock twice had lunch and now
they're having dinner that's a
depressing comment for me who's been
basically on this couch well I've been
going oh this is good okay so I'm still
trying to I think this is a game right
it's let's see you know what made me hit
that this I or maybe hit the camera and
we did that let's samurai hey let me let
me take a quick yeah baby punch up here
perfect now Levi how long you been
working for the other show um just over
three and a half years the young buck I
mean young the young upstarts yeah as
they say was there any is there a okay
we just said hit the perfect we're back
we're back you could show the game now
okay you could go full screen on the
game if you want there back there he's
got headphones on he can't hear me
that's okay Oh God classic library close
screen on the game for me thanks man
alright she's got some kind of an accent
here she rolled the are and librarian
hmm maybe she's an actress just like
preparing ballpark I hope so
you know this is this whole game is just
a small place Oh camera I'm just putting
it away okay
can we meet oh okay oh well well well
okay Marielle this is a part play by
that is a sick jumpsuit I agree I like
the fashion this game this guy's got a
great lapel going on over here are we
going to sneak into mom's pantry later
and steal all the pop-tarts
I don't think so that's someone that
knows a level after this yeah right the
mom's pop-tart low mind okay looks I
don't think she sounds Russian she
sounds like French oui Levi you're
Canadian right I am are you can you
speak any French I the smallest amount I
had to take it up to sixth grade great
sex in Canada whoa great stay changing
sixth grade grade six yeah yeah well
that's useful how do you write your
dates videos adjusted but yes normally
we just go month day year okay even our
computers okay
as opposed to year month day right year
month wait you month day here you got
lover face online most computers go here
first don't they oh my god I don't mind
out anything my brain is mush how do you
write your dates month first yeah yes
yeah you write it the way you sing I
write May 9th
yes right yeah okay yeah so maybe tops
it maybe Canada starts with here I might
have turned over so much to the US
system that I forget Wow you've become
one of us one of us to wanna Google
goggle one of us right little freaks
anybody know oh wait the game so he's
this is this is basically a sleepover or
a lock-in however you want to say okay
so he's oh this dude he's a little sure
thing in this game is you get to control
cameras I think so you're just well you
maybe try tapping on his oh yeah oh now
his phone Oh mrs. cool I like the
wallpaper are we on a train it feels
like we're on a tribe of this game I'm
not sure I still don't know if it's
called Republic or république I was
Terrance and Phillip an accurate
representation of Canadian I think so
yeah okay pizza face is a realistic
illumination 83 thank you for missing
your other stream to watch our stream I
think that's really nice it's using our
stream or don't tell me how to live my
life ok Joshua oh man oh you're right
today is better to organize I agree
that's I think probably why I think your
month day because that's how I say it
miles
I planned are you an organized but I'm
not like a hoarder I'm just gonna say it
planned an hour of file talk [ __ ] how
could we buy I love it my mother they
attempt to one of the ones he's gonna
come out that's a great question
we have some onesies over here are these
so credit I'm so was too I'm opening
yeah this is like I did bring out the
bat at one point kind of a fun this is
yeah yeah I gotta say this is one of my
favorite parts on working our show is
the props Sam we got a great prop
Department built all John row I hooked
us up amazing props Jen who loved this
bad as a trip last year's comic-con he
used this exact fake bat for when he was
a therapist for superheroes oh my god
yeah this is great so we got a Goldblum
Batman's old one that's amazing I gotta
go it's got you know what I see why you
would like it it's very balanced you
know it feel it it's got a handle I can
feel but then it's also soft right you
know it's got a good bounce and soft
sturdy fakeness to it yeah like like
Jeff himself
[Music]
oh you didn't I say Republic did he say
Republic Thanks ah it's Republic Oh
finally oh my god I can rest easy now
those big rock club in Calgary where I
grew up rock club yeah republic nice
actually go to one called southpaw in
Brooklyn pretty cool we good yeah one
time I saw a guy there's a great Bank
called seitan aside they're like a fake
heavy-metal band the guy did one of the
coolest things I've ever seen in my life
and that includes like sunsets and like
people getting married one of the
coolest things I've ever seen Jase he
was playing guitar solo on stage falls
into the crowd the crowd he's like he's
like to the bar to the bar still playing
the solo the crowd carries him over to
the bar puts him up on the bar they pour
drink in his mouth he's like back to the
stage falls back they carry my the stage
was amazing
who's unbelievable is better than a
sentient oh my god way better sunsets
happen every day when you see a guy pull
over to a bar take a shot pull back okay
so she's just said she's infected
contaminated for reading something
animal Oy yes they said Republic she
said so did you figure out the I before
is it I think you just hit the I yeah
and then I think you hit the other eye
yeah that I we're like you know when we
are we're like lawnmower man we came
that's true or like that one electrical
gremlin in gremlins to remember gremlins
to but it did he travel through the yeah
they were really reach and I think for
gremlins to yeah
really had to hype it up know right with
yeah oh yeah that was a female gremlin
right yeah that made me feel weird yeah
I'm not sure none of us learned our
tight line is I feel refeed tall and
green spot little lizard do you feel bad
I feel like we're raising a sullen
teenager and I don't know how to
we would be terrible Americans bit
horrible parents she's sad what's going
to the camera against Jason brings over
the fact that sunsets actually happens
in the evening not in the morning guys
I've been streaming for seven and a half
hours you got to cut me some slack I'm
the old one sunsets happen question
checker so it is good to have fact
checkers I agree okay you realize most
of your audience says no I do a lot more
man is okay I'll explain it one more man
is the amazing great American actor Jeff
Fahey plays a man who I think Pierce
Brosnan isn't it too right here's
president the only one I knew in it what
do know Jeff Fahey the actual one yeah
yeah the the titular Elan tight celerity
how do you say that word to to teach
Euler sorry about that this is supposed
to be a clean stream a lot more man I
basically he gets super smart it's kinda
like the Johnny Depp movie transcendence
but at the end he goes into all the
phones and he turns into every phone's
right I'm not sure what's called one
more man I think he was more yeah I
think he was initially his lawnmower man
whose present was a scientist so it's
kind of like a gardener who becomes like
yeah right yeah it's aspirational yeah
it'll be omnipotent and probably inside
the electricity it's every gardeners
dream basically so she is talking to us
uh-huh when we're in the camera oh she's
like she just asked if I open the door
I'm gonna kick over to any point I'm
happy to play every wanted to talk to
distrain I don't want to make you play a
game I do like to turn talk to the
stream talk to a stream journalism
okay so now we're out out out so far
there's a lot of hoodies and cameras in
this game mm-hmm you know the crouching
yeah Cooper's calling I said please do
not be alarmed by the sound of my voice
I mean my name's Cooper I wasn't until
he said please don't be learned
you in text-to-speech because it is too
risky for me to use my real voice really
I am the one who found the phone and the
girl's room a moment ago I have returned
to known to her because she is in danger
and I wish to help her
it seems you wish to help her - that's
not it cut to the chase yeah you are as
technically inclined as I am so I will
submit additional lingo and get directly
to the point
minute three of the conversation I'm
just gonna skip right to the point you
access to our facilities online network
it is called Omni view Hey by entering
he's skipping to the point leaving Intel
that we were to keep the girl out of
sight you'll need to scout ahead for the
rest I do love games that just come
right out and say like the exposition I
like we don't care about the story
here's one phone callers gonna tell you
exactly what to do by the way
sometimes my humor gets lost in
translation
that's right Michael Glen says is 24
hours the longest you've ever played
video games ah not really
I'd like to say yes but probably knows a
little Stephen Hawking - the voice are
you again I leave are you a gamer I
don't play you know I played a time when
I was in like elementary junior high and
I would stay up days on end I didn't get
in - oh no didn't go beyond it's like
Playstation stuff because I liked it too
much and I didn't think I'd get anything
else ecologist right I've done I
couldn't start I need to see all the
levels and I need to see all those
details in them like so with choose your
own adventure books and like I hear
every I wanted to go back oh I get that
- I did that's it yeah I don't like
missing do you so you're kind of you'd
say you're a completionist so like
there's so yeah if there's like a
hundred gold rings you don't need to get
them to beat the game get a special
treasures or something yeah you got to
get shorts yeah fair enough
completionist I like it um I am the
opposite I'm just like let's just get
this game done as soon as I started
getting am I hate playing it and I want
to finish it
yeah I'm like that with a lot of things
like a movie I'm like alright let's
let's get you just one of
you know okay I get it Cormac MacCarthy
okay yeah yeah the road fine what's at
the end of the road fine fine so are you
trying to get through to any end any
type of end screen it's kind of like I
think I'm just so afraid of commitment
that I don't even like committing to
like a book for two hours I just like
okay let's just get to the end of this I
don't care what he let's just you know
let's finish er yeah I'll do like a
Wikipedia I'm even like read the
Wikipedia article of a movie I'm
currently watching I think it's some
kind of a THC to get to the end of it
yeah oh for sure gistic so I'd like do I
need to watch the end of this no weirdly
I finished every movie except for blue
heat or blue Miami and Alec Baldwin
movie oh yeah both ah man I was just
saying I'm at Britta who's just here
that's the only movie I've ever walked
out of is that the movie where he's
eating any and he's crouched around his
plate he's yeah dinner with a cop and
the cop says oh how long were you in he
goes what yeah that's it because how did
you know he goes oh cuz the only person
I've seen protect their plates like that
is former prisoners oh my god and then
he gets his fingers cut off he comes
that scene all the time my god holy crap
that's amazing
wow this is incredible i sat through
that whole oh how was the end okay all I
retained my scare people away I think I
did hard time maybe he was just napping
and eating Wow okay well like that it
okay so alright here we go
alright after a while the game and gets
impatient
it's a pitch with us the guy gave us a
50-minute phone call also we get bored
of this game you can also switch around
you know we got other games okay we got
24 hours at games here well I mean I
like exploring hallways yeah you know
rate so far these hallways are pretty
fantastic
what's with the grey alien that's ah
that's a girl in a that's not an alien
it's a it's a woman in a suit that's
what a woman in a hoodie looks like yes
sir yeah right exactly it could also be
you know it does look like also one of
those like workout
things where it's like a rubber suit and
you want to sweat a lot oh yeah you know
yeah
that's right level up oh oh oh here
comes Oh God Oh this is horrifying a guy
in a turtleneck we're the subjects
straps does this dude have on him oh
we're over there can we can we
pickpocket
oh boy this dude needs to he's got a
bulk up I mean that's not he's just put
us back in that house so oh good we got
that we got our photo negative already
well good we're back in this room
because this was a place of comfort that
I now yeah okay um I do love my favorite
thing is when you look at the chat and
they say something like Justin Bieber's
long-lost sister and you have no idea
what they're talking about
Aaron was-- what do you how is that
because bieber wears a hoodie where are
we going with that what does that mean
okay take two we're trapped in the back
out David bird he did look like a guy in
a 90s techno punk video so many straps
just so many straps on us all the time
all right here we go okay there's a
pickpocket button over there I'm gonna
have that does well that opens up so you
hit that it gets rights it's grayed out
option so it looks like the stuff that
we're supposed to yeah okay really well
that says they don't bother watching
movies I just read the Wikipedia because
I'm too impatient I have to know what
happens well you know there are some
cool things like Oh me on this dude
again strong guy okay interesting so
it's a game where you continually get
back in your room yeah that seems to
make it a real feat further every time
you escape that's just what happens in
Republic you know you're realistic this
is what would happen that's just what
Republic is all about they're not okay
well good thing is we've really got the
hang of getting locked in this room
waiting yes and then right exactly I
think it's uh we're really it's a nose
please notice me noticed we keep hacking
it open okay all right so good night Kim
Oh see you later thank you seeing a few
hours the case huh mostar says this game
is called you're grounded
that's exactly right okay this we've
done this is the only way we can go so
this has to be right all right saying
that destinations miss oh can we hide in
that Oh Oh behind the locker there we go
perfect
ooh there's a cool little magenta view
of us the creative that was the goal of
the game I don't like your freaking
trigger the guy and then quickly hi
that's a good idea
these eyes don't blink this is a really
depressing hallway how do we know the
guys coming can you just keep running
down the hall what do you just keep
running down this way oh wait we came
from that way came from that well we
came from in there designed this hallway
this is like what are we even doing this
is like a sub-basement depressing I
think it's like this you know function
is I believe it's a real thing energy
flows through a room you know like you
want to have like a mirror when you
first come into the room to kinda remind
you like oh like life is you know right
here never anything you know like
post-apocalyptic approaching
revolutionary gaming 13 we just noticed
you there you go hey loud meows this is
like airports either you get mrs. Locker
the blues this is a republic is what
this now is anyone giving us tips on
what to do next
uh yeah does anyone Christo just wrote
depression which I agree with
that's right
the bluesy for just joining us mrs. Levi
mcdougal hello amazing writer for Conan
leave I wonder some of the things you've
written that people would know oh wait I
don't want it I don't want to question
you while you're about to be grounded
English today can we get to the locker
error this guy's just standing here
that's oh nice oh my god great job that
was incredible
good moves good moves okay stay over
there huh
Oh kid no Locker getting a locker yes Oh
perfect okay this is good this is good
new screen this is good there's looks
like there's deodorant over there
oh no okay the doors shut all right this
is great you're doing great Levi you can
equip this or the girl this is the voice
they chose for the whole game come on
dude where's the girl Sam Drake kitty
not spoon that's right well thank you
peanut bead three okay so we definitely
got pepper spray here we go also like I
just have something to say it's not that
I sneak around a lot and I'm not like a
spy or anything sure but don't you think
Levi's common sense would dictate if
you're so worried not supposed to be
maybe you shouldn't walk like this like
you're sneaking around just pretend you
should be there oh you know like have
good posture yeah walk around like you
know a little confidence you're saying
she's asking me throwing back oh yeah
look she's like I don't know where
should I go you know it's like I'm all
I'm saying is it's probably easier to
sneak around if you just pretend just
own it girl she's a little disoriented
here she might still be under the
effects of this place yeah she would we
get poison at some point I think they
were just talking yes she was saying I'm
contaminated Wow god that's terrible Oh
slip that's this is great old bits are
coming up yeah I love it
bad postures gaming cred not for the
people in the game though okay alright
be doing switch games we hate this game
you want it let's switch games this game
if we would just end up in a lot I feel
like Dillon are our due diligence here I
mean I guess just wander around till we
get caught again I think that's what and
then we'll just switch it okay can we
switch to the pixel promise to beat the
game in ten minutes and we've really
fallen through no no no that's a mistake
there's a big target you know wow yeah
you were really swinging for the fences
any game in ten minutes
right any game it Ted that's incredible
I mean that's I don't know that you can
beat a single game in tennis yeah I'm
learning you're right I don't understand
what is that make you Poe to beat this
game I don't know if that's true I wish
maybe people have played this game it's
just I mean it's so much never played
Metal Gear I played Metal Gear and this
is the Metal Gear exactly quit just
exploring an office building yeah which
are three Jews Packard we have a lot of
games lined up for 24 hours and we're
gonna play another one here and about
all republic it's for the next 19 hours
oh yeah which is Bobby we're gonna go
over 24 hours because we love Republic
so much I'm just get it all on this
level see ya
tell your friends tomorrow when you see
everyone with Republic this is a call
center we're just in a gala everything
is in seven to eight hours people will
start to come in to do their job that's
right that's okay my chairs
okay so here's cool it's actually you
get I'll keep wrapping the game while
you guys figure that out yeah I mean it
could be you could be winning this game
there's no way to tell you 11 the
developers could be watching this thing
how did he get that that's not a level
we creation it's like in the matrix what
he's in that Whitehall at you're seeing
your code feels to me
I swear I'm I'm more fun to hang out
with play when I'm not sure this is
amazing I'm adding a planet you're
making this game fun which is incredible
it's um it's like a magic trick in
itself what do you think is created by
the gun oh my god wait now we're in some
kind of vampire mansion here we go oh my
god we're like in Dracula's v4y a fully
restore this this whole hotel yeah it
just it just turns into flip this house
I know this renovating oh no that's very
time oh we got all night this is a
marathon with that door almost like it's
it's one of those what
I don't think so oh good night I don't
think it loud meows is going buh-bye
loud meows Jessica it's ruined just go
through it this is a pretty nice house I
mean I think they need to clean the
floors I don't know why she's crouching
here in kuselias oh god it's Cooper uh
hiccups let me get right to the point as
a child I always loved the game Tetris
yes finally a game where you update your
software in the game fantastic after a
long day of I'm dating the software on
your phone yeah
now you must remember your password what
is your challenge question Oh God
need to head to the commissary well oh
he said he's added it to our map do we
see where the map is my god Jesus we
just need to get you caught and then
leave you alone I think she should just
you know what
how do we pepper spray ourselves Adam
just oh she thinks this is good thinking
hmm just touching differently to the
screen joke's on you well well well
good thinking I can't see me here
there's no one around good thing too hot
hide clearly we in a vestibule
okay so Natalie gearheart you've been
witnessed she is a teddy bear she's not
her best friend in this I don't think I
don't think she's helping herself
Joshua masa here that's a really fun
game
Kevin Cromer we're playing a game called
Republic I'm here with Levi have a
Duggal hello every writer on our show
we're a thing about 24-hour mobile
marathon sponsored by Google Play we're
on you know what they took me a really
long time to figure this out we started
at noon
so we're seven and a half hours in
because it's 7:31 Pacific we're playing
until noon pacific tomorrow it's so many
hours 20 of which will be spent on
republic wandering around trying to
figure out what you know all the hours
up to this one has anyone gotten this
far in Republic No
so this is you are seeing groundbreaking
gaming here by Levi ground the back to
boring record we take someone with no
skill set okay John SoCo flappy bird uh
no you know we did just play badlands
though which was very much like flappy
bird meets limbo which was super fun we
are going through door that's right oh
yeah Levi are there any jokes over there
go sketches that you thought should have
made it on the show oh that's a great
question here do you want me to take I
could take over where you take her um a
lot of them end up on scraps which is
the nice thing about this show that's
right
I played Luke Luke Skywalker
made it forth and it was a really quick
bit that we I think was half an hour
before rehearsal it was made made forth
maybe last year the year before and uh
Conan brought out Luke Skywalker to
explain may the fourth and he just
whispered through an explanation of why
that's Star Wars day look it's it's a
dude right here look at this guy oh yeah
we got a dude back you see there's
another one we got a dude here
oh this door's unlocked we can really
gotta update your software bro yeah you
want to get gotta get to that software
time date nothing more exciting
updating software for a game hey man
heard you updated you saw all right so
maybe let's just hide behind this thing
dude this is like in The Wizard when
Fred Savage has to update his soft all
right here we go three so Mario 3 in The
Wizard oh I think it is that was a first
time this summer yeah the first time
into the raccoon may the force be with
you
thanks real vanilla ice Wow real ice is
what's Nelly Furtado day wherefore Nelly
Furtado's birthday I came out as the
only Canadian to explain the national
holiday and I'm out in a crop top with
her face Wow some shorts from a video
she'd been in while I remembers it after
we did the bit Todd Levin I think was
just on yes he was he'd say good job if
I had to wear that cost you might have
killed mine oh my gosh
and I was new it is nice was
heartwarming he's right apparently saw
the bit really yeah what is she gonna
try to FaceTime or in and we I think a
friend of a friend actually got ahold of
her it was all just a little too late
she said well let me know next year wow
that's amazing yeah holy when is your
birthday do we know is it coming up if
someone just linked to the bit is I mean
it'll be on any calendar December 2nd
all right dang you know what other weird
way that'll be worth the way that's mean
time to AB it up before I have to wear
the cropped up again this is pretty good
oh yeah weird statues I can't get a
handle on this game and what's going on
here yeah just a terrible Republic does
sound cooler than hiding behind statues
games and then you buy it and they've
tricked you in and then
do is hide behind statues how does it
work I have a question for you yeah yeah
so you guys the writers will write bits
for each other a lot of times sometimes
sometimes or you'll be in your own bit
sometimes we'll be in our own job and
it's or anything you if you felt
uncomfortable is there anything you
wouldn't do on earth
is there anything like where's your line
at that I was asked to do yeah wouldn't
ya besides play Republic 400 you're
saying I can yeah I don't think so I
mean I've had people kind of come and go
do you think you know it's usually body
suit like unitard stuff oh yeah no
really good in a body suit that's always
that's the big one that if someone comes
in to ask you to do it you can tell
where they look on their face right you
know so funny is like who's the guy you
ever see that either Neutron movie Tron
recycle they're trying got young weird
young Jeff Bridges yeah exactly
even so that guy who did the lead in
that movie I don't know it his name is
I'm sure you've worked out he's got a
personal trainer and just like you know
it like yeah he went on a cut and create
even he looked terrible in a bodysuit
like that was uh whatever eighty million
dollar movie wonder million dollar movie
they couldn't even make I'm sorry to say
but the dude did look a little goofy
because it's kind of knees were and you
just don't nobody looks good in a
bodysuit nobody you just right I was
wondering it's impossible sorry what
movie did the worst or flu the most
under the radar with someone changed
their body the most Oh
so Satan Tom Hanks lost all the weight
for castaway sure but it was bonfire
these are some movie that just went
unnoticed right oh right rather where
that you mean the transformation they
had to do it they gained 200 pounds yeah
and then it went straight to video well
there is a famous thing of Matt Damon
for courage under fire there was a movie
where I think that's like where meg Ryan
is this yeah
amazing hero and then there she dies
spoiler alert it happens like in the
very beginning but then these people
it's like I want to say Denzel
Washington is interviewing people about
whether I should you get the Medal of
Honor and Matt Damon who has kind of a
very small role in that law
a crazy amount of waste and he's not
even hardly in it yeah and and to the
point where I think he like went running
like every day and ate a big potato and
they had to be out of heart medicine
because the heart rate and he died he
actually died yeah but luckily like a
lot more day they uploaded his
consciousness into me all the phones and
no bracelet along Mormon yeah it's weird
I don't know you know it started off
it's it that you know they they went a
different direction with him
this is we're really wandering around
quite a bit it really is
it's it's kind of I could see I a nice
mellow Sunday afternoon yeah maybe I you
know we only got like 20 minutes left
maybe we switch games oh yeah should we
switch it or do you want to all right
we're gonna switch it up we're just with
you another game now this might be a
more insane okay it might be more insane
than walking through oh yeah it's true
it's true but I think to running through
hallways
hey guys on this one you can run statues
on this one this one is a little game
called final fantasy a new empire okay
you know final fantasy I've heard about
final fans what have you heard what did
you hurt let's hear I mean they've been
around since like 8-bit Nintendo hasn't
it yeah yeah it's a very yeah that's a
great
I don't lastly franchise yeah did it
look similar to the first Link and Zelda
game I believe it probably digs I think
kind of all games looked exactly like
that yeah um is it when were you're
walking around a huge Empire and you're
encountering people and gathering it
could be right now it's a game that I
think needs to have a little restore the
software update with so much oh yeah the
support we never get you know what we're
still gonna let republic just kind of
stew in its own juices for a little
while while we figure out what to do on
how to get the software update because I
think the real cliffhanger leaving
people without this awful yeah yeah I
think it was pretty intense and
absolutely and this game is fun alright
here we go
have you played this before I've never
played any of these games
never played any final fantasy I will be
played for clues gamer we did a final
fantasy we did a final fantasy game I
think it was 15 I believe okay with
Elijah Wood who was amazing who's
actually a huge fan of Final Fantasy oh
this looks this looks complicated this
is 17 hours per level wow this looks
there's a flashing thing I don't know
what's going on here this dude's hair
looks cool I show you said oh the heart
of the Empire okay he'd be Republican
ten minutes it was incredible Oh upgrade
see this starts with the software up ah
they're making Arabic that's how you to
instantly complete the building okay I
think are we creating a new empire
building university oh it's a boy no
we're doing something worse now we're
just building now we've moved from
hallways to building highways and what's
known as a cleaner you bring me in to
like play all the games you don't wanna
subject others to know you're they I
knew what I was getting into
you're like a closer at baseball yeah we
bring you in and when we need extra help
yeah what you need we don't know
crouched behind statues this thing is
just nothing crazy pictures I don't know
that the other okay there's another
great game I don't even want to enact it
because it's too fun of a game called
space plan where you literally just hit
a button over and over and over it's
exempted and I by the way I Spit this is
a true story
that's bass player will play space play
a little later space plan is a game work
like it's basically like you make energy
this is so dumb I'm even Sainz and with
potatoes and stuff and you have to hit a
but if you hit it the button it goes
faster and I was so into this game I
went out to dinner just by myself and
was moving the entire time
editor a space plan all I'm gonna load
it up and we'll play spaceplane - yeah
you enter that uh and I was so addicted
to this game that everyone in the
restaurant thought I was a complete
crazy person which I guess I was because
I was tapping on I yeah yeah game to
make potatoes you just resent there was
an old arcade where Tehran you had to
hit the two buttons as fast as pop oh
sure yeah what was that he would get
tissue and slide it back and forth with
Eric
Smart's remember seeing like the guys
didn't have to do they got to that level
and I would pull the tissue they brought
it and you slide it but protists you
approach issue right so I don't so we
switched from what they were always to
building a university yeah and that
might not be there any where we run it
we run a dry cleaner we make sure to
read all the labels to make sure we're
not using any other wrong solvents yeah
you know we could also play a game
called run sausage run you want to play
that game
yeah absolutely yeah this is gonna be a
really exciting game Levi prepare
yourself here we go run sausage run this
is gonna be bad as if it doesn't let me
build a university within the first five
minutes no thanks I have I'm promising
you right now sir okay no hallways
setting no universities lots of sausages
right prepare yourselves just Conan's
gonna run sausage run that's Conan's gum
has everybody who toot on it no one had
only mo Welch your you can take a little
bite of it if you hit mo but did mo
really she did yeah she took a little
bite of it she's gonna live forever
it slowly morph into Conan yeah I think
that's exactly what's good right exactly
it's like a weird all right
I love run okay someone loves run
sausage oh this is gonna be the opposite
of everything in theater let's take a
look at Rogers ready we got ya look at
this game amazing Lou beer we were in a
hallway can you bring it up a mouse all
right here it is okay oh you're dead
yeah dad you died in me that's it you
done died
now kick pik like rats out of that now
way I want it
okay do you know what I did wrong I
think Joe so I think can you hold it you
go back and you run there you go oh
goodness is that the only thing you're
doing that yeah it's just run sausage
run this is all this is all actually
this is mummy we only got 15 more
minutes with you Joe I don't think
there's jumping but it better how do you
know you can you got a sweater I think
you got a soda yeah you know what
Levi life is not just Adam Adam at a run
it's also its slowing down you know it's
uh
it's uh you know oh wow that was that
was good but very brutal I'm starting to
miss hiding in a walk oh uh you got any
backside of that there you go okay so
now when it says tapped run it kind of
means hold damn I think it's trying to
throw you off because I think it
actually does mean to hold down you're
doing great so far
weirdly this is how I run at the gym
that's a horrible idea
yeah it's bad Dutch bad for your back
you don't want to Danny had a posture
with that something all right perfect
let's go fullscreen uh that's all I'd
like to point out look at our amazing
sausage bag huh you like that
oh yeah sausage background we got
everything okay oh oh oh you're back see
it's all meat but this is all all action
for some sausages all the time and if
you think I talked about space plan
without showing your space plan you're
crazy cuz I'm definitely gonna show you
space plane but it is the opposite of
this game it's a slow long burn wait
this note oh my god you're doing so well
and sausages here there's yeah not in
the space it's space no one can hear you
sausage oh that was unfair that was
unfair that was unfair okay well VA
gonna do a run all right yeah like give
me a run here give me a ride here we go
I'm not good at this yeah and by the way
I watched you do this and I can't even
do it yeah man pull it together pretty
tough hey hey you know what yeah I'm
kind of missing the hallway I'm not
gonna lie to hear the homey it was quiet
there's probably good music I know in
about an hour I'll be at home and the
first thing done my Hispanic really is a
software
you're just kidding it's gonna haunt you
forever it's funny they say you know
what they say is you get a you get a
song in your head because you don't
finish the song they say like that's
kind of and that's how you get a song
out of your head is by finishing the
song if you have a song you can't you
know like Weezer say it ain't so for
instance Weezer I love that song if you
finish the whole song go stop thinking
about it you're only gonna be thinking
about that game it's like it's like
those songs that just sort of fade out
and don't really have a hard end the
worst the worst like American Pie Don
McLean you know one of my favorite songs
wreck of the Edmund Fitzgerald good
party sauce sure that's Canadian oh yeah
Gordon Lightfoot right yeah they're
legend lives on from that ship way on
down yeah the lake they call it get you
Jimmy yeah never gives up for dead Oh
what the hell oh you know what you got a
run over the water it is okay
oh it's like in life when you have to
run over a bunch of plays exactly to the
gun this is very nerve-wracking by the
way is this yeah yeah t14 or something
oh I thought that was water
I got no all right here you go it's your
turn okay all right so far I think I
would rank no sausage one sausage run
uh-huh
and then I go Republic and then I go
Final Fantasy just because you know it
was until the University do feel like
Final Fantasy so so popular there must
be something to it yeah we must be
missing are those German sausages in the
background I'm not sure what kind of
sausages those are can you tell what
kind of a sausage is by its I feel like
photo words this animation we would know
if it was German there would be some
very overt jerk Germanic yeah thank
maybe to be wearing a dirndl or a what
are they later hosing oh sure yeah boy
yeah well I mean I ran across the dishes
I was so excited I forgot this
what kitchen is this that has a knife
sticking out of the wall just doing this
is one of those lenses sausages run
through no okay yeah go yeah that's not
a sausage running to ring get this
Pentagon talking I've been okay these
gamers rated C for cleavers is driving
high-protein sausage you know I will say
I sausage is not great for you I'm just
gonna put it out there that's a lot of
salt with fat masazi true oh man a lot
of human blood
a lot of a sausage which is not you
wouldn't recommend that
come on I mean you know what you can
make a sausage out of anything no
frankly I mean as sausage here's a
question frankly frankly would you know
do you do you feel like a sausage is
more the naming of a form of food or is
it what a food is comprised of for
instance yeah ie
could you make an ice-cream sausage and
would it be called an ice cream sauce I
feel like anything you put in sausage
casing okay so you're saying it's a form
that's that's interesting
why did there's probably vegetarian
sausages being marketed out there okay
as long as they all right let's follow
the student in sorts of shape you could
trick someone into eating in pretty much
any let's follow this - okay let's say I
got a whole batch of spaghetti alright
and I got a new sausage maker I just
bought and I got nothing else but this
spaghetti I want to put and do it now
it's just spaghetti yeah not meat sauce
it's not sauce just new - there's no
butter just straight-up cooked noodles
could I make a spaghetti sausage what is
that sausage casing I don't know now
that's made of meat that's the meeting
in sausage wait it's the casing normally
I mean like haggis sausages I'll test it
they're using any parts of what I think
traditionally sausages thin membranes
from blokes yeah yeah like this oh Lord
yep Oh Lord love a duck guys you've
solved it here I'm trying to come up
with new ways to not swear in the Lord
love a duck is what I got
is that bad are there any other Canadian
phrases that are like you know like Oh
nuts and berries you know let go like
probably regional stuff mostly the East
Coast Nova Scotia new plant they kind of
have all our best phrases they how they
do them how man cuz I don't know cuz
America doesn't have great freezes you
know colloquialisms like that everything
so right what's a Great America anybody
got an American phrase like like shiver
me timbers that's why do they say that
that's a paraphrase everybody pluribus
unum shiver me timbers yeah yeah that's
what the pyramid is it's a shivering I
don't know what a good like I mean like
BWR unb run
that's from okay boot scootin boogie
yeah yeah
but Canadians I feel like you guys you
guys you guys got some good phrases up
there I'm sure we do you know oh now
he's thinking like a net loss song from
the East Coast Cola guys to buy ice obey
the bilderberg oh my god are you having
a stroke what's happening I thought
everyone knew I remember something of
the writers and realize no no it's good
because like nice debate the builds
about it nice debate it sales it I used
to buy the kitchens efficient take
someone's dollar a sir this is great now
are we just seeing that for the rest of
this stream that was amazing alright
this is okay Oh
what am I just go straight oh my god
this is my god this is oh boy
whoa I don't know that we can play this
on the stream you guys would you have a
bondage sauce thank you now here's the
thing it's just a sausage it's an
abundancy I think they heard you talking
I always him get hidden just he's plain
spaghetti
what if I was boring can you make it so
do you make look at the double sausage
you take a sausage and put it in another
sauce and I just saw it at a place here
I saw bacon-wrapped bacon
oh it's deli whether it was Canadian
bacon with sausages on the side and a
normal bacon wrapped around it and then
they sliced it into thin slices you know
what I know we've put a man on the moon
but somehow that's more impressive to me
you know I don't I don't agree with
here's one thing I'm just gonna say as a
general rule I think bacon is delicious
it doesn't need anything else man don't
put chocolate on it
don't glaze it don't wrap it around
other things you're just making it more
inferior sure you know we're at peak
it's like taking an apex predator once
it ain't like a like a like a like a
lion is that Mapex burger
sure yeah right you're taking a shark
and you're gonna put a bunch of little
ferrets on it now it's not gonna make it
a more vinegar than fair no no I'm
talking about like trying to improve
upon perfection my shark is millions of
years oh you're wearing a suit of armor
yeah but this would help you I've been
wearing this for hours God oh I've been
hallucinating your eyes what did you get
here really how long have you been here
I've been talking to myself this is you
know that you know me you know this 24
hour stream is gonna add with me waking
up in my apartment have you met this I
use land do you know I was I took a
bunch of concert there a big is there a
big reveal at the end of this I think
it's gonna be I know what he knows but I
did murder mystery I don't know I'm
gonna I'm just gonna wander out into the
hallway never return I think off into
the woods I should give Republic to one
of the interns under way yeah no wait a
second so going back to the shark tank
the shark okay yes apex prayer millions
of years of evolution millions you care
to wrap your head around what a million
is a million toothpicks would like fill
up all that the soul building or so
ready right that's how long evolutions
been working on a shark it's perfect as
a creature now it's like saying okay now
sharks are pretty dangerous yeah we're
gonna put
we're gonna strap Ally into it now
that's not gonna make it a better
predator it's gonna make it a worse
printer that's how I feel about bacon
check you followed me on this bacon
sorry honey what is sure I'm saying
about the it just bacon is an apex food
leave it alone it's fine it's great it's
delicious got a strap uh-oh I shrunk
Katie Lou shield says Erin I love you
come to my house and play video games
I can't I'm doing a 24 hour stream King
you know and by the way he's working
through hallways with me oh yeah I'm
screaming about bacon and sharks and and
watching a bondi watching Levi play a
bondage sausage while screaming about oh
come on but you feel me on the bacon
thing people have learned you know yeah
absolutely
well mind you and then I tried the
bacon-wrapped bacon answers really do it
so yes so they take a log of Canadian
bacon and then they they're just
wrapping the normal bacon around yet
something does - you can always go back
to having normal bacon well that's true
not losing that's that was the only
bacon available I can see him so like
why not strap a lion - a shark every now
and then all right just to test it out I
guess you know we got to keep improving
on things we gotta try - Madeleine Sims
is feeling me on the bit almost starts
feeling me on the bacon thing Lewis
thought says bleh I was thinking about
adding bacon my quesadilla well here's
the thing if you're looking at it from
the point of view of the quesadilla that
yes bacon makes it better you're gonna
have a point of view of the quesadilla
the gas idea feels that bacon makes it
better all I'm saying is if you were
gonna eat a quesadilla putting bacon on
it will make it better grace if you're
gonna eat bacon putting a quesadilla on
your Bacon's gonna make it worse it's
all about perspective guys you know
yeah quesadillas are good you don't
gotta strap a lion to a quesadilla no
you don't need to feed a quesadilla to a
shark or have it go down a hallway with
this software update it doesn't know the
obstacles that's what oh wait what
so if you get the the snowflake Oh
awesome dude you're doing really well
oh that was a shame okay that was an you
know what not cool that he just learned
on your head I do poorly with
encouragement
said something nice no rude of me going
you're doing terribly yeah
cuz it's shopping me Oh personally I
don't know it's ketchup not blood I
think you did someone say that I think
it's for what are common terms blood
sausage or ketchup sighs well played
check and me you know you should do
strap bacon to a shark you know what
don't tell me I'll live but I will try
that bacon hasn't it yes Fabares
you are feeling me on this bacon as an
ingredient fine bacon isn't trying to
make it another better thing no it's
meat juices it's all about the meat
juices guys hashtag meat juices you're
only here for the shirt which shirt mine
or leave us because Levi's got a great
shirt I went pretty neutral but thank
you but it looks awesome it's oh this is
this indestructible very about the bun
very Republic oh my god you are like
owning this game dude you did you should
just quit Conan to become a run sausage
run pro-player Oh at least I died shrunk
I don't know what that means
exactly okay well Levi uh thanks for
joining us thanks very well I do have a
something to plug a comedy album can
people follow you what are you doing on
the old Twitter on the Instagram on
Twitter and leave it
Levi mcdougal at Levi's material perfect
yeah um I'll be playing screenshots of
you feel really bad you're gonna start a
competitor at competing stream to us so
we'll just be streaming your
complimentary together we will be
Republic possibly if I do they'll thank
you
all the time this guy clean
judges plan people what else in a few
bits this week so keep those keep those
eyes peeled closed real vanilla ice it's
MACC in two hours again there we go
we'll put in a link to to Twitter ah
Thank You Liga of course now it's 8 p.m.
we're 8 hours in I think it's time to
check back in with mr. Conan O'Brien
taking away Conan hey it's 8 o'clock
check this out and you thought I wasn't
entertaining this is a mug that was
given to me by a talk-show host when I
did my show in Mexico City a while ago
and la Luna that means I think in the
moon what why is he in the moon corner
hey Suze Koosman porque nadie lo BDO I
think that's because nobody loses is
that what it means I mean I know some
Spanish I just don't know why he's in
the moon and la Luna
why is he in the moon if you speak
Spanish please help me out if you're out
there but anyway hey soos Guzman has a
show and he's a talk show host he's a
cool guy and he had me on his show when
I was Mexico City and I've got this mug
what does that have to do with it being
what time is it now
8 o'clock was enough to do with it being
eight o'clock
nothing except it's always a good time
for coffee
hello everybody welcome back to the
24-hour mobile marathon spots in my
google play we are in our eighth hour
and the eighth Koenen check-in thanks
for checking in coding that's so nice of
you
all right so we've got a lot of special
guests coming up we're not even halfway
through this insane madness that is
unfolding but we've already heard from
Levi mcdougal Todd Levin Andre do
Boucher
ahmud Berber his last name
Perugia thank you I'm in Perugia mo
Welch Aaron Weaver Chris Brinson Chris
Hayes Gemma Paolo the list goes on and
on we played a ton of amazing games and
we've got a ton more games of tumblr
guests coming up and coming up this hour
in fact right after this short video
we're gonna be joined by the amazing
Mike Lawrence but first let's take a
look at his incredible stand-up on Conan
I'm not very healthy spoiler alert
here's how I know I was at the grocery
store I was pushing my shopping cart the
shopping cart the grocery store let me
borrow not the one you think I own and
in it all I had was candy ice cream
potato chips and soda
this little boy looks at my shopping
cart and then he looks at his mom and he
goes mom aah
why can't we have that man shopping
carts and she just looks at him and goes
because I love you
I'm a nerd I have strong nerd opinions
I'm very upset about Ben Affleck is
Batman
right now Yeah right
that's my Syria I'm so upset about it
Ben Affleck being cast as Batman fills
me up with all the rage and emotion he's
never been able to portray on screen I
have another strong nerd opinion I'm not
a fan of the Star Wars movies here's why
because I saw Spaceballs first blow your
mind by the time I saw Star Wars it was
just unfunny Spaceballs to me I was like
we're all the classic characters I grew
up with like yogurt and Pizza the Hutt
this isn't my childhood I love pop
culture the most timeless moment in pop
culture to me is the whole Cogan sex
tape I say timeless because I see it
every time I close my eyes brother but
my favorite thing in the whole Cogan sex
tape he spends about a minute trying to
open up the condom wrapper cuz he's just
like all of us and the whole time I'm
thinking to myself man I bet Hulk Hogan
wishes condom wrappers were made out of
yellow t-shirts
it's okay if some of you didn't get that
joke it just means you have no real
connection with your father I'm going
through Ted issues you know you're going
through really bad dad issues when you
watch the movie Finding Nemo every day
but you turn off ten minutes before the
end when they reunite because that's not
how real life works cats on the cradle
is my ringtone that's how bad my dad
issues are my dad literally sent me a
Christmas card last year and it just
said Merry Christmas from our family to
yours I'm poor I realized recently the
difference between rich people and poor
people is that rich people constantly
talk about the amazing things that
they've done in their life while poor
people just constantly talk about the
realistic things they hope to achieve
someday like a rich person will be like
and then we went to Paree and had some
croissants and then we went skiing in
the Swiss Alps you've never been and
then a poor person will be like I don't
know how and I don't know when but one
of these days I'm gonna go to a hospital
I love watching reality shows like duck
dynasty and swamp people and here comes
honey boo boo
but they shouldn't be called reality
shows I came up with a new term for them
poor nog Rafi because that's all they
are they're just shows about poor people
doing sad stuff that rich people can
masturbate to oh yeah eat that skinny
people are always wondering are the
people on those shows being made fun of
yes they are here's how you know if your
characters are speaking in English the
entire time and their words still appear
as subtitles at the bottom of the screen
you're being made fun of I'm from
Florida originally swamp people
represent Florida is not a great place
and you could tell this by the names of
our sports teams like one of the names
of our sports teams is the heat that's
it the heat we surveyed a hundred bother
Jews and asked them what they hate the
most about this place and we didn't want
to go with their number one answer the
Cubans
I want you guys to know that I'm not
racist even though I look like every
villain from Django Unchained and here's
how I know because the low black girls
black girls where you at yeah hey you
want some of this you know what they say
once you go Jew there's not a lot to do
but this is why I love black girls cuz
black girls have the amazing ability to
predict the future and this is how I
figured it out in middle school I asked
the black girl to dance with me and she
said you're ugly ain't nobody ever gonna
dance with you and it's been 15 years
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to the
24 hour of mobile marathon sponsored by
Google Play we have an amazing special
guest coming right up you just saw us
stand up it's Mike Lawrence get in here
buddy thanks for coming man we think of
our green screen background I'm sorry
we're wearing black it's slimming it's
nice living color especially against a
bright blue bracket I don't look five
years older than I did that I just
looked 55 I got gray hair when I was 14
so it's funny because like as everyone
else around me his age I just look yeah
just look the same you'd even know Steve
Martin was the comic he was just an idol
to you yeah use a hair Idol yeah he also
does comedy oh you want to know my I won
Steve Martin story which is obviously
I'm a huge fan of comedy and Steve
Martin but he was on our show and he was
doing something the banjo and we came
out if we have a morning meeting every
morning at 10 o'clock and we all kind of
piled out of the green room and as us
walking out he was standing right here
with his banjo yeah and I turned as I'm
walking up and I was just so taken aback
and I just go nice banjo and he just
went what are you talking about and
that's how I embarrass myself in front
of my comedy idols so there you go hey
everybody hey pink unicorn yes we got a
new shirt on not famous on the internet
either there we go I'm Mike and I are
gonna play a game call this silent age
right now I haven't I played a second of
this game it's a puzzler are you a fan
of puzzles yes we're gonna play the
other one who do I play a woman who
can't speak and then Edie has sex with a
fish that's it that's basic heard it was
award-winning that's the whole game
that's the entire game so yes Oh miss
Little Miss otaku loves our beards well
your beard is killing it over here
that's an amazement
that fear and by killing it all the
sexual tension ooh Oh contraire Mon
frère I think it's only growing oh yeah
we look like the only way we could get a
woman as if we made one with a machine
and I've been trying back over here for
the last eight hours that's really what
this stream is about all right so I play
a young Sonny Bono only the lab guys get
to go down there oh and Frank of course
they all have read access cards that
Frank's not allowed it's just Frank
Stallone good old Frank man I'm probably
making way too old reference we kind of
got a little struck I love me some Frank
Stallone what was the movie he was in or
the dancing one not breaking oh my god
what's the Frank Stallone movie agrees
to or Greece - hey North horse would
watch us in a weird science reboot oh
nice there we go we're lovable fellas I
thought the TV show is better than the
movie hot take whoa my goodness that is
Paxton but the guy who played Chet who
was also in Wayne's World fantastic how
many good chance he's watching us on the
lights wow I hope so it's one of those
thick rubber gloves you for cleaning
things in the labs and strangling my
wife yeah perfect staying alive is they
Thank You Heather quarters thank you
guys that amazing about the internet you
just ask any questions yeah what's that
what's that cartoon where it was like a
duck who was also a man Oh duck man yeah
God boys you take not it was man duck
boil again
I do love all out of all Batman's
villains man that was my favorite
because it's the most lazy they were
like what a Batman was just a real what
if I was a real bad oh you mean man-bat
it was just created by a dyslexic kid
yeah exactly but I think like Man Bat
ended up being like the son of Jay jonah
Jameson cuz he got no no no your guys in
your streams to cross in your oh right
to do this Marvel DC I know you've been
an hour
I thought in wait I've worked only as
long as every other person at this point
but what about animals man wolf that's
what I'm - yeah with moonstone moonstone
right there we go there we go
so not man Batman wolf but man wolf yes
John Jameson's John James J Jon James's
son John yeah who's an astronaut yes
there we go it yeah you got a jewel from
the moon right into a man wolf yes where
is the logic in that like a jewel from
the moon makes you into a wolf thing I
love it okay I'm just basically doing
stuff I would do in real life
that's the point of this game yes the
silent age is basically just do work son
yeah that's what it says heard of the
end is you just learned to love yourself
and no one's ever gotten there yeah
exactly I would never beat it Jerkins
all says you look like a young Charles
Bronson alright I'll buy it like a Once
Upon a Time in the West maybe yes or a
more out of shape Bruce Vilanch I love
it man the real vanilla ice just said
Man Bat is awesome I think you
mistakenly put a question mark at the
end of that because man that is awesome
well being bitten by a radioactive
spider and give you superpowers instead
of some because I suppose a moon rock
attorney Oh to a wolf look but you could
follow the logic of a radioactive spider
turning you into a Spider Man where does
the wolf like a werewolf for the moon is
that we're talking about yeah but all of
his villains they did J michael
Straczynski did a story arc in the 2000s
where they're all like totem based so
the lizard yeah it was one of those
things that he over thought that was fun
as it should have been all the true
stuff yeah oh the blue key card is in
the closet says Davis held her Hurlburt
thank you also like way to just keep
like toxic waste in the office Bros I
guess this is the 60s these are just
film reels from Transformers
had to seal them up forever and you're
like by the way this is also being
sponsored to you by transformers exactly
it's not the last night it's the third
to last night no wait Steven is asking a
Mike we had a blonde conversation Levi
and I about bacon
yes all right so what is your bacon
opinion in terms of adding it to other
foods um people have run out of ideas
with it yeah
people run ideas but you support any
other way you said it stands on its own
yeah thank you thank you Mike exactly we
don't need to add bacon anything again
is the JK Simmons of foods like not need
to be supporting other foods I'm gonna
see it on its own yes exactly yeah
exactly
and it's salty and delicious let Cave
Johnson be Cave Johnson
you know like JK be JK so now I had that
access marking but I've got a oh do I
use oh do I use this access card I see
okay machine 73 we're checking YouTube
chat or checking twitch chat or checking
facebook chat we got them all up right
here I got all three of them right here
I can see all three of y'all okay it
means no kind of character I don't know
the venom character isn't is it things
you can't take back is the alien
symbiote right symbiote yes Scipio it's
not it doesn't need a justification it's
an alien it's not like a moon rock is
turning him into a werewolf you know
yeah well they actually retcon in the
spider-man cartoon that John Jameson was
the one who brought the symbiote back
trip to the moon they did yes yes he
made sense because I'll be honest with
you let's chica I thought that in
spider-man 3 John Jameson should have
been the one who became venom because
Kristen Dunst the Mary Jane leaves him
at the end of part 2 oh thank you Peter
and he's an astronaut so he goes to
space finds a symbiote and he has a
reason to hate Peter Parker that's
brilliant
yeah and instead they mike lawrence
celebrity or just falls into a park it
was terrible
cuz sam raimi didn't air he's like what
will happen agile
I love it
Halloween needs to put you in charge of
more venomous crypts are you excited
about this new Tom Hardy movie or not so
much I mean just looking at the trailer
and it feels like they're ashamed of
making a venom movie like they did the
exact shot from the opening a full house
with just the golden great fridge
everywhere and the gardening car this
car is gonna be in it I don't know my
favorite character ever was they did
this thing in the mid 90s called the
amalgam first okay
even the Nerds are like this is too
nerdy for me where they combine all the
Marvel and DC character they do like bat
Vereen and stuff wool verb and there was
dark cloth ah there we go
but Captain Americans spider-man were
somebody right Captain America and
Superman were super soldier spider-man
and Superboy worse waiter boy but spider
boy had a villain named buzz Arnage yes
Lazzaro I would write the bizarreness
movie you know that that's how the
entire thing started with somebody made
a bizarre dad joke they're like let's do
whole thing bizarrely just sounds like a
band that opened for coaching okay
bizarre niche puddle of mud in college
and this is so boring and it's like
raining outside yeah this is he's kind
of walking with a strut though he's like
dude this this feels like if the
crash-test dummies did a video game he
does have a great stache by the way yeah
I am so bored this game is awful the
penguin and Batman is just a penguin
because he's obese and as a pointy nose
possibly laughs like I hope she throws
me out the window and then screams what
kind of forever be like they'd be like
the beginning of madmen where's the key
dude
say someone dumped an urn in here I
could have sworn oh my god this game is
very silent the silent age it did
promise that but sorry it's like a cross
between carnage and Slenderman that's
funny and I'm sure there had nothing to
do with venom yeah so I saw they asked
uh what's what's my favorite superhero
movie yeah let's hear it funny you
should know so the podcast that I'm
gonna be doing in April is called with
great popcorn yes and we rank and review
every superhero movie from best to worst
Wow oh my god they'll find out I'm not
gonna ask what the best was but what's
the second best the second best I would
say might be a move it's tough because
there's been some great ones recently
that 2008 an Iron Man I mean wow yeah
you know it would either be Iron Man or
the Dark Knight Wow okay
there we go that's probably the best
year for comic book movies cuz you also
had Hellboy 2 oh my god he should've won
an Oscar I like that actually I only
tell Boyd's you better in Hellboy I did
- yeah it was great because the first
one felt like a TV pilot totally they're
just getting too much out it was it's a
lot to explain it's a lot yeah but then
when he's just doing stuff it's fun yeah
when he's just Hellboy be in Hellboy you
know that's so Hellboy officially called
it Hellboy to you that's so helpful oh
and when the next spider-man movies just
called that so Kraven I'm already where
I was before
this I hate this game yeah this is this
is a lot we can switch games yeah now do
you want to see space plan one of my
favorite games of all time you you might
hate it are you almost actually will
here's my favorite thing like just a
quick thing Secret Wars where spider-man
first found a symbiote
yeah the way they came up with that
title was that they just picked the two
words that kids like the most group yeah
like what words you love secret and wars
dude please
then then space plan it's like alright
what's your favorite word and what's the
most boring word you ever heard they got
you know space invaders that's a classic
yeah space plan hahaha space folder you
were gonna hate you're right you're
gonna hate oh man I can't wait for space
inside yeah I I gotta say this game
though it's weirdly do you are you like
do you get like addicted to things like
you get yeah alright then you might you
might love this game because it is
incredibly addictive let's see if I can
find it on here they just have a game
called boxing yeah boxing on a second
I gotta go this way with it space
planning here no it's my space plan is a
little game I don't know I came across
it okay so Marion's got bored and then
they opened on excel sheet oh my god
they're gonna play balls all right balls
the fighting game from the not that cool
it's just it's just a bunch of balls
that go up and down it's crazy
so much is that's what's the best x-men
movie there isn't one movie has none of
the is that what's the worst a superhero
movie
Catwoman what are we talking about oh
man that's I'm gonna go listen to my
show
if I had to say I mean we're gonna come
up with zubi me and my wife we're gonna
figure out things together so
would just be me but I just had to say
right now I'm gonna go Superman Returns
wow it's the only one I've ever walked
out of definitely the one with the the
most blown promise I think cuz it was
positioned to be a huge movie yeah they
could have done some really cool fun
stuff I mean Kevin Spacey back when he
was an actor right yes right and not
just the second worst part of that movie
besides Brian's right yeah I know you're
ruined a lot of childhoods in many
different ways should have worked
it should all right all right here we go
we got space plan now look here's the
thing we got a word out put her over
here it's telling us what to do word
space we don't know what's going on all
right like we have no idea what's
happening yeah Parvez all messed up
wakey-wakey now we just got to tap that
button okay yeah just get get some power
go in there man yeah get some power
going you're gonna hate this game I
can't wait there we go we got some watt
huh a lot of cool noises in this game
though so this is just the game this is
the game you just have anything I'm
happy to tap it for you if you just want
to watch you talking about movies
literally it's literally tap a button
and it tells you so thing maker hasn't
see everybody I feel like I should get
that bird toy from The Simpsons and just
have it back and I'm like I found a way
to be three times exactly this game
exactly no wait here see we could hear
the other thing we can do is now that we
got some kind of watts we can get a a
solar panel can repair a solar panel now
we can net oh wait we gotta get some
this game guys is called space plant
it's weirdly one of my favorite games I
can't tell you why I really this game
has only played by Doomsday Preppers and
70 year old virgins
yes exactly that's me
no I'm the virgin category do you got it
we got a potato here boom this game
feels more Canadian than the last guy
you had oh you know we got this thing
called a space plan
we just press a button and not much
happens besides that but you know I
think rush is a very good bad Phoenix
chassis tap a button lame now see you
would think it's lame but then you start
adding some panels you know you start
getting your uh this is this is a little
that's not that's a little planet around
the side just love that one day
something to be like back in my day we
had games like space plan where you just
hit a button it was so hard like grandpa
aren't you from 2018 where they had a
PlayStation 4 they were all before you
oh yeah we hurt the button and we didn't
think about our crumbling marriage and
it was good
yeah we ought to play this very long I
do have a Marvel gaming could play
that'd be fun nice I just want to show
you
it's called why was Stanley and black
pants yeah I've got a dashiki on let's
go wander what did you think about Black
Panther loved it yeah I want I want
another movie just with Lupita and who's
Michelle from the walking dead from
their Ogura
oh my god I just feel like 300-pound fat
nerds we'll see each other at Comic Con
open their lips and they'll both have
the word space plan written on it it's a
secret
Nancy now he's a black forever now we
got some Watson rebirth I swear to God
i weirdly addicted this game this is the
first time I've watched another person
play a video game and not been envious
no you just keep pressing the button
president me purse it for all the
children who were never able to do I
says you know what's going on here but
we know we like it oh there we go see I
love it I think they made this game for
amputees to be okay with being amputee
gorgeous or just for people that can't
continue buying the little bird toys
this is some guys like you know what I
didn't need my hands yeah I'm good
that's right man this is joke music we
got some good music
it's pretty chill don't you feel like it
or not lounge right now chilling out TV
okie did all the original music for
space plant yeah exactly
wait til the drop hits the Earthlings I
have played that see box says you know
what this is the second time I played
this on the stream I've actually played
this before on the stream it's super fun
all right I went to a restaurant playing
this game and everyone thought it was
crazy like they are now I just can't
believe you're doing this in the 8th
hour like you're a better the way to the
marathon and you're already like peaking
its pace plan oh oh yeah oh this is the
best game alright I won't make you play
anymore space plan it's so great though
look how many potatoes we got Mikey
what's really wrong here we got five
potatoes what's missing in your life
this is paper they can't be destroyed
this game so much look how many souls we
created what if this is the future of
gaming what if instead of VR it goes
back and it's just space plan can you be
quiet
the music from every Cinemax porn I
jerked off to when I was 17 is playing
alright here we go we're gonna play in
this music be playing in a manual not
show all right here we go you just tap
on that thing and I'm gonna get the next
game ready here we go
I'm tell you space plan you know what
you're gonna you're joking about it now
but in about never you're gonna love
that game about 10 minutes to never oh
you know what it's actually out here
alright let's go full screen alright
see I had to tear it away from you that
was crazy I was like good white give me
back space play really this game exists
just so I can appreciate how advanced
pong was exactly okay we're gonna play a
little game called
if I can find it on here what is this
tube so I'm looking forward to number
three which no one knows where it is
here o malley stole our tablet well we
need three cuz that's got the game on it
so you guys you're just joining us we're
here with Mike Lawrence it's coming on
the new podcast called with great
popcorn you can find it on the all
things comedy Network and of course you
just
corne a new comedy album tell people
about that yeah it is called the just me
league yeah and it would be cap city
March 21st through the 24th doing a
whole new album of comedy yeah totally
worth checking out and that's awesome
you should be more enthusiastic about it
than I am
guys guys if I was plugging this album
before I played space plant I would be
excited about it that thing's sapped my
joy
don't worry you're gonna get it back
with Marvel future I came into this
having fun and I'm feeling sad and
misery oh no space plan is the three
billboards of video that's what I do
that's mice that's my secret power is
bringing people down to my level of
terror
this is Marvel future fight yeah Marvel
future fight this is we have a lotta we
have all the characters of Black Panther
here nice black panther we have the
other guy and then we have the dude with
the one-hand claw and then we have his
sister who is a badass
Cherie Cherie that's right Eric kill
Marv you can go fullscreen yeah are you
black mere fact massively
she's amazing in that the black Museum
and I know that's a good yeah yeah now
if you had to rank Black Mirror episodes
what would you do what's your favorite
one I think my favorite one might be I
don't know that Star Trek one this
season was a may have well I think the
pilot is still the best pilot I've ever
seen for a TV show because it makes a
very bold promise that you think it's
gonna deviate from us gives it to you I
know that so many shows amazing tease
but don't deliver and that one deliver
and I was like I'm hope now Mary chew
married you alright let's look at this
game here whoa here we go I'm gonna turn
this up actions
talking to blackball by the way black
bull versus store I mean you got to go
black bolt right know what black hole
over the buckboard or black bull what my
faults a one-hit wonder he's got the
voice and if you could survive that in
your fine that's [ __ ]
and basically as Black Bolt starts to
speak the word could use me owner to go
into an alternate dimension
black holes exhausted I love he just not
some Apple the hell I love it perfect
yeah yes I've ever thought of this you
just wear down black yeah
[Music]
oh they're gonna sit back says we've
been waiting for this one all right now
how does this now space plan or future
flights just I know you haven't played
future fight for that long and you did
play spaceman for much longer which one
is your favorite so far I mean one is a
video game and the other is oh man but
enough about marvel future fun yeah this
burski this does look like it could be a
mini gaming injustice that's true I
heard if you beat this level Black Bolt
apologizes for the inhuman step that's
the first time he speaks
ouch he's like it I thought my voice was
destroyed Oh JT now says I like the sin
Junipero episode I agree that's a good
one
yeah that's an easy answer though a lot
of people said they liked that one itani
no I kind of thought like it's fantastic
it's great but like the 16 million
credits was I like that better thank you
yeah I thought I liked the darker one
sans Junipero I mean it was like best
dark one is shut up and dance
it has the sad accenting cuz you're kind
of rooting for this kid you're like oh I
hope it's through this there's nobody
good I also really loved metalhead was
great yeah people crapped on that one I
know it's awesome yeah it's just this
very simple you know I heard though he's
like Charlie Brooker initially wrote
that we're at the end of metalhead so
metalhead is a a lastly fury road meets
black mirror yeah exactly and it's
basically uh these people running from
the this release wrote this robot that's
kind of a dog robot that's like the
perfect killing machine anyway and at
the end of that you I heard that he
initially wrote it where it's a person
like the person steps back from the
controls and go gives his kid a bath
instead of it just being like an
automated death machine thing which I
think really takes away from the whole
thing I mean that would be I don't know
it's it serves a different point other
than kind of
led you going while dog robots dragged
in America yeah I do love me some I do
love me some fallout will be playing
fallout shelter a little while nice just
fine Oh Jack Kirby the only time is now
very gonna appear in a Marvel King
Chaka Khan was awesomely creepy I agree
I love Jesse Plemons by the way that guy
fantastic she was good too who's Tina
Maloney but he was yet cuz it's like
good he really didn't make you root for
him yes and that first absolutely Oh
metal that name has already been taken
yeah because he owns that too great
exactly play Final Fantasy game a little
mr. talkie we did play a Final Fantasy
game last hour you might come back to it
how could they keep making a I feel like
this is a jury sign for a bit for nerds
like yes how can there be another Final
Fantasy the Final Fantasy you finished
you don't there 14th and before time
movies how are we still above our time
at this point we should be at time a
tight twenty inside though ah Nick H
what game is this this is Marvel future
fight we're play never ending story to
your en de draak Kevin we're gonna be
your leader of the battle begins Captain
America oh come on fight alright any
leftover orphan black I've never seen it
but I hear good things about orphan
black is it's it's got canceled nobody
knows you know here's the problem with
video games today oh boy here we go
let's hear it I just want to play yeah
how long that she took to yeah the
silent age we were walking around for a
silent age yeah all right what's the
deal
it's all right side quiet and it's taken
forever
the silent a dime here 15 minutes trying
to download
the app before I just got to be cured I
put in the corner I'm humor
the graphics are sweet though I love the
graphics on this one I'm standing around
and doing nothing that people deserve to
hit me America yeah look at all these
look at all these Ultron's trying to
beat you up yeah I got him what Captain
America is kind of a jerk he's like I
got this Tony back off yeah somebody
wants the glory
shouldn't you be breaking Natasha
Captain America hey I'm from the 40s
hey Karen I'm pretty liberal caranesca
Mel I just downloaded this there we go
Rockwell had me at Galaxy Quest M
Rockwell's awesome poster he's really
funny at Galaxy Quest
he's greatest fantastic and Iron Man 2
oh yeah I agree
people always say that's one of the
lesser of Marvel movies in some ways it
is but he makes it so work he's fun he's
fun and everything yeah he's great at
Galaxy Quest yeah I mean that's
basically part of why I love that
Callister episode because it felt like
the Galaxy Quest pilot we wanted but
never gone right I agree I agree well
I'm shocked they never made Galaxy Quest
into the show yeah tico go Final Fantasy
was meant to be one game it was such a
hit they made more well dope but I'm
saying is we're gonna call the Final
Fantasy IV
think ahead think about scale but just
another fantasy yeah call it really call
it I you know next fantasy or yes whoo
there we go perfect you know I gotta say
something why do people make giant
robots wouldn't be so much worse and so
much more hard to beat like a thousand
tiny robots you know yeah why are you
making one giant Rumble you can just
punch we could make like a thousand tiny
be robots like black mirror and then you
can't stop the bees
man exactly it's iron we have three the
worst of the three movies I liked Iron
Man 3
I thought it was fine yes it's you know
what it's a really fun Shane Black movie
yeah not the best Iron Man movie and my
problem is it's the bait-and-switch like
you have Ben Kingsley who's an
incredible actor yeah as Mandarin and
I'm like alright I want to see this I'm
excited to see this the promo pro
wrestling fan that Tony cuts on him of
like I'm going to movie yeah and then
you replace him with fire-breathing guys
Pierce and God hears is a great actor
too
but not equal to ensue Ben Kingsley as
the Mandarin I agree okay
I do love Shane black though and I love
that he was a predator that's a lot man
look at this we got some Ghost Rider
Ghost Rider has the lowest power in the
world which is that when he looks into
your eyes you feel all of the pain
you've ever made other people feel
that's awesome
yeah it's called the penance there yeah
basically just like a parent I want to
do it to my dad for not being in my
wedding
yeah okay northwards I agree
hundred-percent want an actual Mandarin
degree yeah I mean it's a tough
character to do yeah in 2013 yeah but
still any chance of Ironman for or
rebooting I don't think they're gonna do
another iron I think he dies in infinity
war yeah I think that's part of the deal
there yeah I think that this is his time
to go and it's gonna be really sad but
it's like I feel like we're gonna get
the new phase of Marvel movies and he is
the old guard yeah that's true he kind
of kicked it off yeah
Craven says oh who's your favorite
Marvel villain of all time yeah it would
be The Sandman The Sandman really I've
read every
Wow I just love him oh my god I made it
my favorite superheroes the things so I
just love rocky - yeah because I'm one
but the Sandman is just yeah like I know
people hate on spider-man 3 I love when
he fights him in the armored car ride
like he's fun happy dr. doom which I
don't think they'll ever get Doctor Doom
right on the screen I think he's got too
many cool things and no one will ever
just do all of them and he only works if
you do all I mean I think he's also
weirdly like too nuanced of a character
like I think like it's so easy to go
crazy with dr. new and be like he's
super smart he's got the doombots he's
got me you know all this other stuff and
but he's also like the ruler of a
country and I think he's got a really
cool motivation yeah but it's tough
because it's like you've got to do like
that his parents were like wandering
gipsies which there's some
insensitivities there sure so they've
got to change that in some way you got
to do that he was a jerk roommate which
makes him yeah the most relatable
yeah you know that's it he just he's
just kind of any puss he's just too
powerful he's too powerful to put on
screen Richards did you drink my last
Lacroix he's still I love like him and
boxer shorts but still wearing the mask
somehow yeah what was like in the the
one that they did and she doesn't fart
but they just made him like it evil CEO
it's like let's no gotta have like the
magic power oh yeah totally all the
writers loan those little mysticism
things here there's so there's too much
yeah so you like to buy stuff now or
what's he employers on here
I know keep going man you guys are just
joining us we are with stand-up Mike
Lawrence the hilarious and amazing Mike
Lawrence you've seen him on our show
you've seen him all around you can I
catch him at the Mike Lawrence on
Twitter Mike Lawrence call me on
instagram and check out his new podcast
in April with great popcorn on all
things coming
very exciting we're talking if you have
any movie questions this is your guy
yeah I know about nerdy some of these
comments Nathan mentioned that Iron Man
had his head ripped off in the Infinity
Gauntlet comic book and he did by a
female version of Thanos that he created
with the gauntlet yeah he just made a
girl perseverance amazing and it was
awesome yeah yeah I wonder how crazy
they're gonna get with infinity war and
Thanos like yeah because that's pretty I
mean he kills like you know he killed
like he what he but makes because
Captain America the one punch it's nuts
and also like the whole nebula thing
will probably happen yeah just keeping
her on the edge of death the entire time
it's a little rough well the only thing
is like in the comic you know he killed
everyone but then like they were all
brought back I feel like a few people in
here have to die this is why this is my
pitch this is what you do are the first
10 minutes of infinity what movie to
movie shoot right it's supposed to be
but are not saying I think they're
supposed to be this is what I would do
in the first 10 minutes Thanos comes to
earth the first person that he kills
Stanley he ends the cameo Stanley is a
heartfelt good Wow
oh wow yeah he just with the just the
hand just crushes his head
Stanley horrified or would it be like
Stanley is like pushing a kid get out of
the way someone's cringe is just crunch
and people would be like he needs to go
down now it would be in automation for
it would be so amazing right if you've
seen him since like the first blade the
vampire dancing with a bunch of like
ravers it's my blood it's my blood and
I'll bleed it if I want to
that would be insane yeah yeah I would
love to see that I would love to see the
Marvel Universe makes them like like
choices
you know make some hard choices cuz I
kind of keeping every ball in the air
and every plate in there yeah and it's
hard I mean you know it's like you can't
even then even kill Rhodes did they know
yeah nobody I mean he fell from like
fifty thousand feet an iron suit they
didn't kill Rhodes but I'm about it ah
nice
[Music]
good game that that that rate you I hate
them
it's like I I'm not a fan uh yeah we
were saying to leave I earlier he like
he's like a completionist he loves to
get like every single thing and like if
it's a gold you know silver bronze he I
say get gold on every level I hate the
entire thing yeah it just adds replay
value that there doesn't need to be well
I mean I appreciate it for some people
and I appreciate like okay in certain
games if you want you know extra
whatever or you need want a special mode
then you got to go do this I appreciate
that but it's not for me I like the
story and I like to just keep going
through it I'm not a big fan of you know
right this is what I'm talking about I
let's just get through it man let's yeah
let's go there's too much reading in
video games to what I want to read I
agree to whatever those things are that
just a hat back when we played space
plan
[Music]
james pack up the amount of superhero
movies being pumped out is so tiring i
agree i mean i think people are starting
to i think people are starting to really
experience some superhero fatigue which
sucks i disagree in the sense that they
are getting better like Ragnarok was
fantastic let's chew then they go Batman
was incredible Logan was great Black
Panther was great or so it's like yeah
there's fatigue but they're also
starting to hit their stride in a way
they haven't before and the reason that
they're the best they've ever been is
that Marvel is letting the directors
make the movies they want yeah that's
true you know like Ragnarok felt like
what's he teased film totally yeah and
and you know my Panther felt like
googlers and the more that we see that
then the less fatigue we're gonna have
right just maybe a BSc you know some of
these like depressing sad bad ones yeah
you're not gonna be I feel like I can't
mention them by name because we're on a
lot right now yeah yeah I would say like
I think like I guess what I'm saying is
it kind of feels to me like a lot of the
Marvel movies my worry is they all feel
like one kind of tongue and and I like
the differences like princess I think
the Dark Knight amazing movie yeah it's
really fun it's great it's serious it's
different a lot of practical effects
which I loved you know it feels like
grounded in a real way I love that I
don't think I also love Marvel movies
but I liked seeing that difference and I
enjoyed Marvel's starting to do that
like I said I didn't think there was any
similarities between Ragnarok and Black
Panther but what about the I mean the
color palette like these things like
they all kind of look I don't know to me
a guy yeah I got you know what I'm
saying there's a visual house style yeah
and that's
okay but I think like I think is there
I'd like to see him kind of switch it up
a bit
yeah you know it's kind of like do you I
really love like the new Hawkeye by Matt
Fraction
yeah so awesome
yeah Hawkeye you know I got a bit oh my
god yeah yeah and the art is great it is
different and so yeah so the hot guy
from whoever read it hot guy Matt feel
like it's six years old now but well
yeah that's true
thank you but but I put in terms of it
being like a dip how your own and feel
it's refreshing it's fun
totally and like there's great there was
this great vision comic that just that
came out not too long ago it was like it
did you see that it was like a little
less than a man little more than beast
and it was basically the vision creates
a family of engines and shows Tom King
yeah and it's this amazing thing you say
that as you knew I was fighting the
vision know that sizing
Wow the character later one mention war
machine and then I started beating up
more machine I love it well I mean we're
all living a computer simulation anyway
yeah so it doesn't matter but no but I
think in a knife fight he'll on me he
describes his speech Tesla SpaceX man
yeah I've been like in so the vision
comic is all about kind of you know like
being different and like how his
family's trying to fit in and Washington
DC but then also like being an Avenger
and all these other things and it kind
of deals with different themes which I
thought was really cool I got a big
problem of this game of what is it let's
hear it there's no villains like I don't
know why I'm fighting the vision and war
machine like hey you're fighting your
friends
where's you know the melter or paste-pot
pete or task master or electro in a
house - oh de Linkwood says it's more
like sequel fatigue not superhero
there's some storylines that should just
die off and dig me rather haven't
dragged on and on like The Walking Dead
I wouldn't say that's true yeah
I agree 100% yeah let's let's just end
it man like I like a good and yeah when
we get a green arrow movie I like green
arrow as a character yeah I heard there
was a movie a few years ago that they
were trying to make called Super Max
where it was just a green arrow in a
prison look with all of these
supervillains and that would have been
awesome that's fun yeah I mean like the
raid but with superheroes oh my god the
rate of is insane
yeah the raid 2 is even better I know I
haven't seen it I haven't seen it it's
so worth it did really they they really
upped the ante that's good they do like
cuz the first one cost a million and
this one cost 15 and it's like the guy
got to do some stuff like the first one
is just incredible
yeah but the second one is like a
masterpiece fighting robots I love it I
love it
Michael Glen yes I changed shirts I'm
trying to change as many times like a a
52 movie and then countdown I don't know
NBC can't get their stuff together I
think they're just trying to rush it
like and like Mike said like what I
remember is like a 2008 so they're like
10 years of like setting up infinity you
can't just then do I just don't think
they know what they're trying to do
because like Batman and in the movies is
like this grizzled veteran who has a
Robin who died has a Commissioner Gordon
with a bad signal right but is also a
creature of the night the police have
never heard of food brands people it's
like you can't do penguin jokes but then
also have him be this like you murder
that's true that's a good point I just
pick up Batman right
just pick a Batman already would you
yeah would you just pick a Batman just
pick up Batman just sounds like
something of Maggio's that a kid in a
target we gotta go just pick a Batman I
told you could have one backup Batman
this new Joker movie sounds exciting
though oh I've heard about it yeah
Joaquin Phoenix it was gonna blow Joker
apparently oh and Todd Phillips later
Richter of The Hangover it's supposed to
be Martin Scorsese produced what yeah
what's it gonna be like Arkham Asylum
easily
it's a based on I think it's like that
maybe bits of The Killing Joke okay oh
my god yes my favorite henchman and all
of comedy the aim guys the BP forgotten
wait now who's the head of aim its MODOK
mmm good nice organism designed only for
killing oh my god wait who is MODOK he
was creating the lab by who
dad I don't remember but he knows that
someone was like I was about to be your
friend hey guys yeah Pookie great who
created MODOK I can't believe I'm asking
that I know that he was originated
generals name I believe was George
tarkington well and then you know I have
experiment or something he becomes MODOK
Seth Seth Buerkle oh I know a new Joker
movie you're gonna hear first
can you play fate grand order maybe
Eduardo will give it a shot
stats boots were there doing a Killing
Joke animated movie and Mark Hamill's
coming back to play the role they did
that last year
oh wow 2016 yeah that's awesome I gotta
head Batman have sex with Batgirl
oh very weird hey you know we're saying
how's it going because you're just
joining us we're playing with Mike
Lawrence amazing stand-ups check out
with great popcorn on the all things
comedy network is amazing podcast we're
talking movies comics and we're playing
tomorrow future fun she's pretty crazy
advanced idea mechanics it's right name
I love em so much they're just all nerds
that was the thing as aim was in iron
man 3 but they didn't do the beekeeper
right yeah yeah that maybe that's why
they're like huge miss Stephanie be a
huge missed opportunity we have not
played class rounds they made MODOK but
out of what David out of what advanced
ideas and mechanic so angry
what character would might the
roastmaster roast if I get the Hulk I've
never loved the whole my favorites do
what I like me when I'm roasted oh man I
love the here's why I love the Hulk it's
simple
he's simple he just gets more angry yes
very easy but it's not really a
superhero no he's not
yeah well I like him as a character yeah
and Ruffalo has done incredible things
with him that was so fun in Ragnarok
it's like I think there's some role
where they can't be in he can't have his
own movies because Universal old Legos
around but he can only be in supporting
role it's kind of great yeah and I'm
glad they didn't go you know like the
whole great Hulk thing like let's have
it
vote off from the potatoes from space
plant ah I was Bert Bert maybe that's
what happens to be in a space plan
you get yourself a MODOK I'm surprised
Davis hurt Bert was at Botox original
name I feel like this music is what
every wrestler had as an immigrant ha ha
from 2003 to 2007 Chris Jericho comes
storming out yeah this is a quasi
original Jack Kirby is legend that's
true New Gods are the best amazing RC
boat people should know who Jack Kirby
is yeah you should be you're Tony I love
it like Black Widow can just punch the
robots
I'm not into punching metal man x-men
Sun SPOT lead team they're working for
the New Adventures team what I love
sunspot does he have the crazy starfish
is that him with the crazy starfish mask
no that's Sunfire Wow - sunspot yeah
Oh Oh charlie go here's a villain
finally finally we get a villain I love
James Spader's boys by the way I was a
huge fan that movie but I thought I mean
he's James Spader is such a great voice
yeah it's awesome you know babe yes my
name is Aaron Aaron is your name Aaron
that's true mission failed
what don't worry failure is just another
chance 4/6 what does that mean
wait mr. DeMarco movies just quote a cat
poster hang in there Mike Tony that
turns all black oh I know what sunspot
yeah he's like legs all black he's got
cool like awesome
oh so when you beat like war machine and
stuff you get to be them and that's kind
of fun choir sure choir attire means
just pay for the age of Ultron more like
the week of Ultron I don't know what
that means exactly constant connieyc you
out to pee in this game can you switch
between the tree on your team or they
just support I think you can switch
between I don't think you can do it
though while you're playing I think what
happens is you choose a main character
correct me I'm wrong yeah and then they
support you so no you can't switch while
you're fighting but you can't when
you're between it's really the interface
is so confusing and I want people to
watch no I agree as opposed to just
angry this is a lightning stuff this is
so maybe there are way more powerful
characters and I could have the game
done by then but you know I'm doing this
for you guys I'm dying for you I'm like
Jesus going on the live she's exactly
right exactly like that playing a
superhero game on a tablet for your sins
prayers and and also fun
Boston public was also a decent show
never saw well you know when even has
James Spader on I bet it was pretty good
though he's thinking of Boston Legal Oh
Boston public was the one about
schoolteachers oh so now I didn't like
what I like cause it was also a dia it's
which HBO as a watchman series coming
out seems unnecessary
I do like for tonight we're playing all
mobile games
I love that someone posted MODOK swords
do you like one cool really needed more
than just the girl who fell off the
bridge I'm gasps am i I don't know do I
care about what's Daisy not really yeah
I never really like I love Ryan Reynolds
in Deadpool I didn't really I never
really liked Deadpool's character just
seemed like I don't know ah the Joe
Kelly stuff is fantastic but they dead
he's definitely overused yeah I mean
it's just I think yeah it's like they
once they don't know it's just everybody
it's kind of a Wolverine
I got like Wolverines a character boom
yeah just eat everything I don't want
ice cream all the time right exactly
exactly it's a better place than a meal
I think all Logan again was great that
looks like I want ice cream all the time
what about Aquaman
I love Aquaman I thought he was great he
kingdom come I thought it was a really
cool thing about him just being like
leave me alone I have most of the earth
to take care of yeah he's awesome I
don't want to deal with you like I think
he's too often marginalized when he
should be he he has all of the earth
like there's so few characters that give
a crap about the
but it's most of the earth I'm like so
it's basically just Aquaman kicking
everybody's ass and he's royalty and I
felt like that was a cool Peter David
who's one of the best Aquaman writers
once told me he was like if you put
Aquaman in Gotham City
he'll be able to handle themselves but
if you dump Batman in the middle of the
asset he's screwed yeah Peter David man
also called future perfect one of my
favorite oh yeah it was awesome
my Strahl is this alright well I think
it's gonna do it it's about nine o'clock
yeah works everybody follow me on
twitter at the mike lawrence follow me
on instagram at mike lawrence comedy
check out his new podcast coming next
month with great popcorn on the all
things comedy network and you look on
the new comedy album at cap city in
Austin Texas like Jared Austin Texas
March 21st of the 24th get your tickets
now they're gonna sell out fast very
funny man Mike Lawrence thank you so
much man nine o'clock inside you're
checking them mr. Conan O'Brien let's
take a look
guys it's a 24-hour multiple marathons
sponsored by Google Play we're having a
great time we're nine hours in which
means it's time for me to put on the
giant Conan head that's right I'm gonna
be wearing this thing it's still noon
tomorrow that's right that's gonna be
what oh oh okay sir defesa with ants so
you shouldn't put it on your head okay I
welcome everyone if you're just joining
us we just had Mike Lawrence here stand
up hilarious we have been playing mobile
games from the Google Play Store for the
past nine hours we've got through a
bunch of crazy games my favorite so far
then mine